there's no time
[Music]
13 o clock hello everybody out there
it's us again and we're doing a episode
163 yes is a little bit different this
time
it's a variety of cases yeah it's like a
variety show yeah my voice is still
messed up but it's not as bad as it was
on that last show that we did I'll be
able to talk a little bit yeah hopefully
it's long we don't like talk too much
through the whole thing and like then
start losing it toward the end of the
show because this might run a little
long cuz I have a lot of yeah so I'm not
even drinking on this show yeah I'm just
gonna yeah let you people be mesmerized
by my sexy boy sexy raspy voice my sex
voice Chinese James I had some [ __ ] like
this I can just the swish like that yeah
cuz we're just recording a little bit
earlier in the day we just didn't seem
like drunk yeah like drinking it like 4
o'clock event yeah yeah but what I
decided to do with this because this
show is going to be going up on October
1st and I thought to myself wouldn't it
be neat to just kind of like focus on
it's not that we don't usually focus on
like horrific topics and stuff cuz we do
but I said wouldn't it be neat to do
just like a more horror you know kind of
themed month you know all through
October yeah and I thought this would be
good too we actually did one I'm just
calling it real-life Horrors because I'm
basically talking about a bunch of
real-life cases that I forgot
oh right Danny everybody governor's down
[Laughter]
move the microphone closer to ya
oh you got to be careful that because
worse because when you move him it like
alright so you might just have to like
oh yeah so we did a similar thing which
I called real-life horror reel-to-reel
or something like that where I was kind
of talking about real cases behind
horror movies and we did one like that
like way the hell back on episode 36 do
you remember that it's like we talked
about we did like the Dybbuk box case
yeah the Philip experiment the
Aokigahara suicide forest and murder of
Sylvia lichens which was what the novel
and movie The Girl Next Door was based
on and I said you know that might be
kind of like another cool topic to
revisit because it happened that I got
like a bunch of topical requests from
like people on YouTube and like people
that email me and stuff and some of
those topics I really wanted to do but I
didn't know if they were long enough to
do like a whole show so I thought well
I'll just like compile them all on one
show and then that'll be like an October
show that's like horror movies but like
the real life story so this would be a
good variety show yeah and will you like
get to cover a lot of ground I don't
know how long this is gonna take cuz I'm
gonna take as long as it takes
it'll take as long as it takes but
that's but that's what we're gonna do I
go take two prime take two hours
yeah probably maybe two and a half we'll
see how it goes since it's five now
other than that just standard shout outs
faceless villain three is out you guys
know that Associated villainies which is
my fiction compilation the second
edition is out in print ebook and
audiobook format so oh that oh that
audiobook finally came out huh how long
how most audio book
Oh actually no it's like it's cuz audio
book wasn't out yeah that's true it
hasn't gone up yet but it might be about
goes up because it seems like it's about
time right but and I haven't gotten any
messages saying there's anything wrong
with it so maybe it'll be out and if it
not than whatever I'll just for whatever
um also for the Halloween show at the
end of October I was thinking about
revisiting our scary stories a type of
thing where people said in like scary
stories and anecdotes and stuff like
that so if you guys would like to send
in I already have a couple that somebody
sent me that I worry on the show like I
said we can read other [ __ ] [ __ ] I can
read some of my own stories like we can
read like [ __ ] public domain stories
I don't know if we don't get enough yeah
well can't be real long at one time we
got one it was a damn it was like a book
I know and it's like I really liked that
one too but I was just like I can read
it too long but yeah about six hours
shows yeah so as long as it's like not
all that long you know what I mean then
I'll put the email address in the in the
description so you can send them along
and we will read them on our fun
Halloween show just like we did last
year cuz they're pretty single like that
so that's what we're gonna do alright so
now let's get to some of these cases
these are not in any particular order
just kind of the order that I've took
notes about them in so as I said we're
gonna cover five different cases on this
show that were the basis of horror
movies at one time or another so star
stories that were the basis of horror
movies yes it's like they're real and I
know these movies you know these movies
that they're pretty common move most of
them are pretty well-known you didn't
know it was based on some [ __ ] it is
actually some of them yeah I think some
of them might be kind of a surprised
people right now the first one I want to
talk about was not only you know a case
that I don't want to talk about in one
that's we that was the basis of some
horror movies but also hold on one
second was what let's do a teaser what
are the movies that they're all based on
you want me to say let's say the movies
yeah yeah what movies these songs are
based on that way somebody can notice
stay tuned you know cuz their favorite
movie might be coming up all right well
the first one yeah what's the basis of
the movie the burning the slasher movie
from the night scene from 1981 okay
which a very young Tom Savini worked on
if anybody's like waited about that the
second case we're going to talk about
was the basis of a Nightmare on Elm
Street yeah you didn't know that was
based on some [ __ ] but it was based
based on some real [ __ ]
it yeah I mean you know roughly third
case based on Brotherhood of the wolf
from 2001 yeah directed by christophe
gans if you've seen that it's a very
good movie and i recommend it
the fourth one would be Wes Craven's The
Hills Have Eyes yes didn't know this was
also based on some real [ __ ] yep believe
it or not yeah a great movie as you guys
haven't seen it and then the last one
the title of it's gonna give it away but
the movie was actually a Lifetime movie
from 2016 called The Watcher yeah and
this was also based on a real case yeah
this is a recent case very reason is it
still ongoing
um the legal [ __ ] is still ongoing yet
it actually started in 2014 and went on
for several years like because it was
out a family being watched mysteriously
by somebody somewhere and send them
letters yeah now this this case in
particular like I said lifetime made a
movie and I've seen it it's a it's
actually not bad they changed a lot of
[ __ ] about it they made it a lot weirder
than it really is even despite it being
very weird but also um I believe that
just late last year like in December
2018 Netflix actually got the rights to
this news story okay and are planning on
making either a movie or a series out of
it okay I'm not sure and I'm imagining
that it will have you closer to all
right so that's the teaser so the first
case that I want to talk about that I
said was the basis of the 1981 slasher
film the burning was also the subject of
a very popular documentary called cropsy
yeah I saw dies how that documentary I
did too and I actually watched it again
today it's on to be for free about
orphanage um it's not an orphanage it
was uh it's a school for disabled
children yeah that they lived there was
kind of like yeah it's kind of like it
kind of like an aside like an asylum an
for mentally ill that was one of the
things that was on now
the weird thing about this case though
is that the legend of cropsy has was
around long before there was like any
murders and [ __ ] to go along with like
the
[ __ ] happened leader so it was almost
kind of like an urban legend that sort
of came true like later on yeah which I
thought was kind of it didn't come true
like in a one-to-one fashion it's like
you know what I mean but it was just
really weird how all these stories about
cropsy now that that um that that movie
that I saw called crops he was
documentary it was true right mmm okay
so it wasn't like a mockumentary or a
horror and talk about yeah okay because
it is pretty weird what happened there
yeah and it's like I said it's not um
you know it's not so much the the
documentary the the people that made it
the couple that made it they also did
one call they did a documentary called
killer legends which um might be on
Netflix still I think I saw it on there
a long time ago and they're from Staten
Island and the legend of crop C is very
Staten Island specific now no one is
sure entirely where the urban legend
came from it's basically a variation of
the killer with the hook hand
story although sometimes he's an axe
murderer he was supposed to be an
escaped mental patient who was like
running around killing kids and stuff
and this I couldn't really find a source
for how far back that urban legend goes
I mean the hook hand killer I mean that
goes back a long [ __ ] way like this
but and this is like a variation of that
um so what this dude supposedly did like
I said he either had a hook or he had an
axe and he would kidnap children and
take him take him this like underground
tunnel system underneath this old
hospital called Seaview Hospital which
used to be like a sanitarium for people
with tuberculosis and it was I don't
remember when it was closed but it was
like a really long time ago so there
there were people in this cropsy
documentary that we're talking about you
know them when they were kids like I'm
thinking like in the 60s and 70s and
that that was like a big like everybody
knew about it like you'd go to like your
Boy Scout camp camp or whatever and they
would like talk about oh you better not
go down here go down there go around
that Hospital or anything like that
because cropsy will get you you know I
mean so and as I said this the
movie that came out of 1981 the burning
actually took you know a variation of
that like that happened at a summer camp
much like Friday the 13th and you know
and and made the narrative out of it and
the murderer and that one was named
George cropsy and apparently the they he
had like a prank played on him by some
kids or something he got disfigured and
he got pissed off so he went around
started killing little kids so the story
goes he escaped from that from for
mental free motion
yeah as a kid or a teenager or something
like that he lived out there kind of
like Jason yeah and was killing people
who are camping pretty much that's
that's one of the variations yeah and
there was a place that was a place
called cropsy it was an institution I
saw no that that was there was name of
the institution now the the hospital
same Seaview and then there was another
one named Willowbrook which I'll talk
about a little bit later
okay so cropsy is explicitly just the
name of that guy yeah and the weird
thing about it is that no one's entirely
sure where that name came from or why it
came to be related to like because like
the only okay like in 1823 there was a
guy named Jasper cropsy who was born on
a farm in Staten Island who was actually
kind of a famous painter later on of the
Hudson River School he didn't tell
anybody far as I know but for whatever
reason that name got attached to this
urban legend about this serial killer
with a hook hand or with an axe or
whatever now the weird thing about it
though as long as this urban legend had
been going on and on Staten Island they
knew all about all the kids knew about
cropsy that was like you know their kind
of debt that was their urban legend from
that area but as it turned out later on
there was a real guy who was killing
people in Staten Island app and kids and
killing them usually kids with
developmental disabilities or you know
various other like mental problems or
you know intellectual disabilities or
things something like that and his name
was Andre R and now he had actually
worked I've seen it I've seen
different sources say he either worked
as a janitor or as a physical therapist
at Willowbrook state school now this
unlike Seaview hospital which was the
tuberculosis Hospital Willowbrook state
school was for you know kids with you
know mental retardation or you know
other things of that nature
now the institution was built for that
but because it wasn't really this kind
of stuff wasn't really regulated all
that stringently in the 60s and 70s
there was all kind of horrible [ __ ]
going on at this place now in 1972 well
I mean before there's everybody that
lived around there kind of knew like all
these rumors that you know that there
was all kind of abuse going on there
there were reportedly they would give
the kids like healthy kids like
physically healthy kids in the hospital
they would give them tuberculosis or
hepatitis rather they would give them
hepatitis like as you know like as a
research experiment like it surprised me
actually yeah that went on a lot right
having on a lot because these were kids
that had generally been abandoned by
their parents there because they had
problems yeah you find out a bunch of
CIA and government groups and
corporations did all kinds of stuff like
that in institutions yeah a special
government contracts with these
institutions the next thing you know
they're paying the government to conduct
research there and then it kind of
escalates into where they're doing human
experimentation in some of these places
yeah it's bizarre and some of it was
going on in Canada you know like a CIA
CIA mind control stuff going on in
Canada where they were taking perfectly
healthy women who were married maybe
they had depression to go in there and
just totally erased their minds using
all that LSD sensory deprivation and
stuff yeah they come out it'd be a
totally different person that's some
spooky [ __ ] yeah we talked about that a
little bit talk about it yeah one of her
yeah s government was CIA was
responsible for it
yeah so didn't surprise me and I also
heard about
about these this particular institution
you're talking about during that
documentary I saw about it basically
healthy kids could get sent there well
that wouldn't shock me yeah cuz you know
the good they could just get kind of
shuffle through institutions and
somebody could go you know I don't like
you you know I mean think I'm sending
you to this place yeah if they were even
if there was wrong with Brad or
something right yes they arrest like a
behavioral yeah just somebody in the
system somewhere I want to get rid of
this kid
ya know they'd sent him there and then
they had like some of the staff are bad
you know like child abusers and child
molesters yeah and you know they were
molesting some young boys and killing
some of them I think they found some
bodies on there probably out out there
for according to that if I remember
correctly I think they found some people
that had been some kids have been buried
out there because some of them died just
like a natural causes yeah you don't I
mean they had an on-site cemetery you
know cuz I'm just got sick people died
yeah didn't that nice addition he was
there for a long time but evidently some
of those deaths were kind of
questionable like the documentation on
him wasn't all that tight well like I
said you know I mean some people kind of
thought that maybe the kids might have
been murdered in there and covered up
whether or not the staff did it or
another kid did it you don't know but
well it wouldn't shock me if like a lot
of deaths took place there just because
the conditions were so unsanitary I mean
it was overcrowded um and like I said so
in 1972 a very young Geraldo Rivera
decided to do an expose on Willowbrook
he was back to his old magic human
baggage semi - yeah yeah looking for
looking for seek [ __ ] Al Capone's
vault at all that mera member well this
was actually a lot more I mean that was
whatever like a wet fart but like you
know this one he actually did him and
his camera crew like turned up one day
to document it and they you know they
weren't ready for them or anything like
that and the [ __ ] he filmed in there is
horrifying Frye still around you can
find it it well and if you watch the
cropsy documentary which like I said I
recommended it's on to be you can watch
for free
they show like clips from Geraldo
Rivera's expose in that documentary
where he went into this place and these
were all you know these were all you
know [ __ ] children you know or
whatever they call them now so like you
know with mental disabilities and stuff
like that some of them had physical
disabilities as well like to Down
syndrome things like that and the kids
were just most of them were either naked
or half naked they were just like
sitting around by wall you know by the
wall just like rocking back and forth or
like sitting around at their hands over
there some of them had [ __ ] themselves
yeah it was just like a horrible you
know and in Geraldo is it's as big a
douche as he is but I mean he was just
like talking about it was just like the
most horrific thing you'd ever seen it
said it's just smelled like he couldn't
even describe like what it smelled like
in there because they just never even
because like I said this was 1972 they
didn't really have a lot of I mean it
doesn't sound like it's not actually
that long ago it was a year I was born
but they didn't really have a lot of
protections in place for people with
those types of mental disabilities
especially if their parents had just
left them there or if the foster system
had just left them there if they were
orphaned or whatever so they didn't
really have any laws in place to protect
them so they would just end up in this
place and it was overcrowded and
everyone no one really cared I guess it
kind of makes you it kind of makes you
question your own value system I mean
what happens when you have kids they're
like that super mentally handicapped
normally probably wouldn't have a real
good quality of life then they get just
discarded in the wild they would die so
what they do is they just put them in
basically a prison and the population
density inside that prison is very high
so then the quality of life declines
even further yeah
and then they're kind of like in a
living hell it's like hell for [ __ ]
mentally handicapped people is it do you
start considering euthanasia at that
point well the thing about it is that
you know when I saw
these clips from this expose it's like
you don't know what those kids were like
before they were put in that situation I
might have got a lot worse in there
that's what I mean so it's like at that
point because I mean you're just like
allowed to like just live in filth and
like not be dressed and like [ __ ] like
that so it's like obviously they're
gonna degenerate if they were like taken
care of properly
yeah and in an ideal world that happens
yeah this is not an ideal world you
can't get the staff that's a big problem
just nobody wants that job yeah yeah and
then you know if you to get good people
yet to pay him a lot and then they
they're under there under budget and
still people don't want to live in that
environment it's kind of like people
don't wanna be prison guards yeah the
people that end up being prison guards
you know what I mean they're not really
that different from a prisoner and so in
some cases you know and it's like even
though I got a lot of respect for cops
cops can go bad because of what they see
every day yeah I mean and I knew a guy I
used to work with a guy who he wasn't a
cop but I knew him but he went through
you know police school he went through
the police academy he became a cop like
while he was working with us like he
started part-time and I saw his kind of
like his loss of faith in humanity you
know what I mean it just started like a
being away every day you know I'm gonna
say ideally you have these kind of you
have kids that are hit handicapped like
this they stay with their parents their
parents take care of them they live the
best life they can that happens
sometimes but a lot of times that
doesn't happen because you know not
everybody not all parents can handle
that yeah that they're they have time or
they don't have time for that because
they'd have to stop their entire life
and maybe they have a careers and stuff
you know
or maybe they can't afford they can't
afford so they end up in these
institutions and it just gets worse and
worse and worse than the so what is the
correct thing to do I mean I wouldn't
want to spend the rest of my life in an
institution like that I'd rather you
kill me yeah you know I mean that's the
thing there's really there's no easy
solution to that isn't there's no good
you gonna send me to a hell like that I
said
give me that lethal dose of damn
morphine yeah I'll wake up later and
we'll see you know I'll see you on the
other side but then how do you legislate
that into reality because you know how
the public will respond to that well
that's all you kill all these you can't
legislate it because because everyone's
situation is different yeah that's what
I mean like I said it's like if if you
had a kid like that and the parents were
perfectly willing to like take care of
them and give that kid the best life
they could give them then it's like they
should be allowed to do that obviously
CRA's amniocentesis it's really good at
it what's common it's obviously a lot
better nowadays because you know it's
it's terrible to say I guess but you
know you can prevent it you can yeah
there's more preventive measures um you
know back in the 50s 60s weren't you
know what earlier than that which before
they had amniocentesis before they had
any of that stuff
and before they knew about like a lot of
the birth defects and like you know
things in your diet or things that could
anywhere miss a good cause in a woman's
age because you know after 40 it
progressively gets more and more risky
yes so it's like you know John syndrome
yeah now that everybody you know now
that most people know those things you
know it's easier to prevent them so it
doesn't you know hopefully happened as
often but as I said back in the early
1970s they didn't really have any
regulations of any kind to protect these
types of children so when Geraldo Rivera
did his expose of Willowbrook it caused
like a huge huge scandal like all around
the country despite that it still took
15 years for them to close this place so
but you know silver lining it did
actually like the scandal that
surrounded Willowbrook State Hospital
actually did lead to new civil rights
legislation you know to concerning
mentally handicapped children and stuff
like that whereas like there's certain
legal things in place now that weren't
at the time and it's because of that now
this guy Andre Rand had worked at the
Willowbrook Hospital and he was actually
kind of a drifter he lived he camped out
in the woods like you know near the
hospital where he
worked out as I said I've seen most
things say he was a janitor but then
when I saw the documentary they had a
couple cops that had investigate him and
they said that he was a physical
therapist so I don't know what's what's
true about that but now so Andre Rand
there had been this little girl whose
name was Jennifer Schwager she was 12
years old and she had Down syndrome now
she had disappeared in early July of
1987 from her neighborhood in satin
Island now she was actually um
I don't know if Andre Rand was arrested
prior to her body being found because it
took about a month about 35 days for her
body to be found they had like you know
fanned out pretty much everybody in
Staten Island because it's a pretty
close-knit community at least it was at
the time and everyone was like really
upset about this little girl going
missing so they had like hundreds and
hundreds and hundreds of volunteers and
they were out looking for her and it so
happened that this one kind of citizen
group called I think it was called
Friends of Jennifer or something like
that and they were out searching one day
and one of them happened to see like
this little patch of grass that looked
like the dirt had recently been pushed
down and said they started digging there
and they found the little girl's body
now because Andre Rand had been living
near in this area and you know had been
seen it at least you know had been seen
in the vicinity and had been seen with
Jennifer Schwager prior to her
disappearance he was arrested in
questioned
now Andre Rand already had a pretty long
criminal record mostly concerned with
children disappearances sexual assault
things like that in 1969 he got sixteen
months in jail for attempted sexual
assault of a nine-year-old girl in 1983
you love this I mean it's not good I'm
just saying 1983 he kidnapped a bus full
of kids they've they kids had all got on
the bus it was like at the YMCA or
something like that he jumps on the bus
and drives it off and like drives them
all to the airport damn what was he
gonna do I don't know like he didn't
hurt any of them and like they
interviewed one of the one of them he
had I mean the kid was grown up
obviously but he they interviewed one of
them in the cropsy documentary he's like
yeah he just got on the bus and like
germs an airport he's like I don't get
it
no it was weird but yeah so they
suspected him and they disappearance and
murder of Jennifer Schwager however they
did not have enough physical evidence to
convict him or hold him but they did
also suspect him now there had been like
several other disappearances of children
in the Staten Island area before in
particular they thought might have been
linked to Andre Rand now these were
Alice Pereira who was five years old she
disappeared in 1972 actually there was a
seven-year-old girl named Holly Ann
Hughes who disappeared in 1981 and had
actually been seen with Andre Rand on
like shortly before she disappeared
there was also an eleven year old girl
named Thai East Jackson
she disappeared in 1983 and a twenty-one
year old boy or man I guess even though
he had a very low IQ like a IQ of like a
14-year old his name was Hank beforeö
and he was also last seen with Andre
Rand and then he disappeared now other
than Jennifer Schweiger they did find
her body those other four kids have
never been found
they've just disappeared and like I said
those weren't the only ones those are
just like the four main ones that they
were trying to tie to Andre ran because
a lot of people said that they had seen
him in the area or had had seen them
with the kids like shortly before they
disappeared thank you
that's kind of what I'm suspecting never
he had a long history it was all in his
area he was skiing with him and they
never seen again he killed him
yeah so so since there wasn't enough
evidence to convict Andre ran on
Jennifer Swagger's death he was found
guilty of her kidnapping so he got a
25-year sentence now he would have been
eligible for parole in 2008
but four years before that some new
information came to light which linked
him to the disappearance of Holly Ann
Hughes who as I said her body has never
been found either now some people like
who were kids at the time came forward
later and said yeah remember seeing him
with her or seeing him take her seeing
him put her in a car things like that
they also there was also another inmate
that he was in jail with and that inmate
said that that he had told him that he
added that he had abducted her so he was
put on trial again for the kidnapping of
Holly Ann Hughes and he got another
25-year sentence so he actually would
not be eligible for parole again until
2037 at which point who will be 93 years
old and I don't imagine that he will
live that long now the thing about it
though is that and they talked about
this quite a lot because the documentary
cropsy is mostly about Andre Rand and
about that case
so they interviewed like a lot of people
surrounding you know and all the
disappearances and stuff the weird thing
about it is that it's kind of hard to
say because I do feel like I mean the
guy was in the area there were several
witnesses that placed him in the area
you know with the kids or around the
kids like you know before they
disappeared but some people have said
well maybe it's just because he wasn't
like mentally challenged or anything
like that but he's a weird-looking dude
and when they brought him out there's
this one very famous picture of him
where they're like kind of bringing him
out of the courthouse and he's kind of
like got his face like leaned over and
he's drooling like you can see drool
like coming out of his mouth so some
people are speculating that maybe he was
kind of vilified because he looked like
that because he looked like he could do
some [ __ ] like that now like I said he
had been convicted of other things
before whether that's what I mean so I
do kind of feel like I don't know man
and so it just seems like he did it
yeah I mean I don't know so here's the
weird thing is that so he had worked at
Willowbrook
his own mother had been in and out of
mental institutions when he was a child
even though the the people that made the
cropsy documentary who if I didn't
mention it before I named Joshua Zeeman
and Barbara Brancaccio who are both from
Staten Island and they actually they
tried to interview Andrey Rand because
the time they made you know he was still
in prison and stuff and they actually
correspondent with him quite a lot like
in letters and you know he's basically
vociferous ly defending his innocence
and said that he never did anything and
he actually agreed to meet them face to
face and they went to the person to
interview him and then he decided he
didn't want to talk to them so they had
to leave they did actually find his they
tracked down his sister and asked him
about because they had just found out
that his mom had also been in a mental
institution they asked his sister if he
had been abused or something like that
but she said no she's like you know our
mom had some problems and she was in and
out of institutions and stuff but she
wasn't abusive or you know she wasn't a
bad mother or anything like that so
she's like I don't have any idea like
she said I don't know if he did it but
it's like I don't really know his life I
don't know anything about him because
she hadn't talked to him for a really
long time so the thing is too that he's
so he had worked at Willowbrook
for two years I think it was from 1966
to 1968 I believe now in this cropsy
documentary two of the cops that worked
on the case they apparently got they
asked him if he had seen the Geraldo
Rivera expose on Willowbrook and he said
oh I heard about it but I didn't see it
and they said would you like to see it
and he said he would like to see it so
they brought him to a hotel room and
showed it to him like on the VCR and
they said that when he was watching it
he went in to like they said they
thought that maybe he was gonna like cuz
he could seem to get be getting really
upset and like watching it and they
thought maybe that he was gonna confess
that's what they were trying to get him
to do like by showing him this but they
said then he just started getting like
really horrified by the movie and
then he went into like this weird fugue
where he just like started rocking back
and forth and drooling and everything
like that and they stopped talking and
they said he didn't talk for three days
after that yeah so they don't know if it
was like some kind of weird PTSD
reaction like from working there or if
he was faking or what so I don't know it
was just a really weird thing now
another person that they talked to in
this documentary was this guy who used
to him they called the most storefront
ministers he used to have like this eye
camera but the name of the church was
but it was like one of those little you
know strip mall churches or whatever and
he had actually andre ran had been
staying in his house like either a few
days before he got arrested or just up
until the day where he got arrested and
this Minister guy said no Andre ran told
me that that he had kidnapped and killed
those kids and he for by his opinion he
said I think it was because Rand thought
that disabled children were unwanted
burdens either on their families or on
the world or whatever and that they
needed to be taken out so he was saying
he was the same as euthanasia yes so it
was like so in this guy's opinion he
said it was like a mission oriented type
of thing where he thought that they were
a burden is [ __ ] I think it was
sexual molestation well it could have
been that too I think it was now there
are also very persistent rumors
particularly still in Staten Island and
this this is probably inevitable
happening in the in the 70s and 80s that
Andre Rand was may be involved in the
process Church which was kind of like a
satanic adjacent type of group which did
actually exist and that him and some of
the other dudes that lived in the woods
around there like procured children for
this call for sacrifice purposes and
whatnot it sounds far-fetched to me that
yet and I do feel like now it the the
the couple that made the necropsy
documentary they were also very
skeptical of this now they asked a
couple of cops about it the cops were
kind of cagey they actually went to
either the Seaview hospital or there
Brook hospital it was like abandoned and
they went in there and they said yeah
there was like a couple little like
crosses and [ __ ] but it's just like you
look like regular graffiti and the funny
thing about it was when they were in
there filming you know the woman was
just like I'm not going in there because
it was like the middle of the night it
was like super creepy and he's like well
I'm going I'm gonna they will really
like having an argument and then they
went in there with their flashlights and
then there was a bunch of teenagers
there and they weren't doing anything
bad they were just in there like hanging
out there like yeah we just come in here
sometimes like tell ghost stories and
like scare the [ __ ] have you show them
stuff like that and they were asking
them about Satanist they said yeah I
believe they're Satanist but they
actually didn't know because they were
younger and they actually didn't really
know about the like the missing kids and
stuff but so I don't know if I by the
Satan thing like I said some of the cops
seem to suggest yeah it could have been
and they did have the process Church but
you know did they sacrifice people where
they have kidnapped kids for sacrifice
who [ __ ] knows I don't know it's like
I'm not gonna say no that never happens
but every time some weird [ __ ] [ __ ]
case like this happens particularly in
the 70s and 80s
somebody say what's a Satanist you know
what I mean so I'm always like a tannic
panic yeah I'm always like really really
leery yeah of anything like that because
that's so easy to it's it's just such a
lurid thing and it's like you can see
why people are attracted to like that
kind of [ __ ] but but yeah so as I said
you know this whole story about cropsy
and on Staten Island and stuff like that
and then this real guy that ended up
being and like I said he was not
convicted of any murders he's only been
kidnapped two kidnappings because that's
all they could get him for yeah they
found the one girl's body but the other
four they never found any bodies they
have no idea what they're where they are
a lot of the people that helped in
looking for the first little girl's body
have continued like try to keep the you
know the cases in the press and like
they will go and look and stuff because
Staten Island it's like yeah there's
like a lot of like decent neighborhoods
and stuff like that but for a long time
Staten Island was like that's where they
dumped all the garbage from Manhattan it
was like this huge you know landfill and
then there was like all these you know
disease hospitals and like in singing
asylums and there was like all that kind
of stuff
and it's like even people on this
documentary we're saying yeah it's like
you know everywhere in New York if you
wanted to dump something whether you
were in the mob and you need to dump a
body it's like you dumped it on Staten
Island so it's like so it's like yeah
there's like nice neighborhoods now and
it's kind of like a nice neighborhood
now but there's like the seedy
underbelly of like all this other kind
of stuff and then it's just weird how
they had this long-standing urban legend
and that it almost kind of like came
true even though I didn't you know
nobody said Andre Andre ran does it have
a look at hook for a hand or anything
like that and I'm actually not sure how
that first little girl was murdered
because she was you know meant I don't
know how she was murdered and the other
bodies they didn't find so so it wasn't
the cause of death on the first month
they found but not that I know of isn't
that strange
probably says pry strangulation that's
the that's what I was gonna say because
that's usually the most common in those
types of situations oh my god
yeah but yeah so so they based it so
what horror movies they based the
burning the burning oh yeah that was
about that was about a serial killer
named George crops anchor and see it it
was good I saw it a long time ago um
like I said I saw it because I was
really into like you know Tom Savini
like all his special-effects work and
stuff and that was well like one of the
first movies he worked on so that's how
I ended up seeing it but at but as I
said so that so that was the basis of
that that was more the basis of the
urban legend whereas if you want to know
more about the real guy Andre Rand
then you should probably watch the
documentary which is just called cropsy
which like I said is on TV because
that's mostly about him it's it talks a
little bit about the urban legend - and
like interviews people from Staten
Island and like diversions of the story
that they heard but it's mostly about
the Andre Rand case so yeah you should
definitely go check those out so the
next case that I want to talk about is
the case behind a Nightmare on Elm
Street yeah yeah called Cambodian sweat
not sleeping debts see that's the thing
I think a lot of people don't know I
mean obviously Freddy Krueger isn't real
just
scared by but it should be noted and I
think a lot of people maybe don't know
this is that Wes Craven got the idea for
a Nightmare on Elm Street from a very
real and very weird series of deaths now
these deaths took place in the late 70s
and early 1980s Wes Craven first written
read about them because there was a
series I believe it was three articles
that appeared in the LA Times now the
one in particular that struck that got
his attention and gave him the idea for
the movie was about a little refugee kid
he hit him and his family had fled from
the Cambodia Cambodian genocide and her
living in Los Angeles and he had told
his parents that he was terrified to go
to sleep because he thought he would be
attacked in his dreams and would never
wake up hmm now he did finally fall
asleep and his parents were relieved
except after he fell asleep in his room
he started screaming his little head off
as if he was having a nightmare and by
the time his parents got into his room
he was dead no [ __ ]
real case yeah and it wasn't the only
one so it's just what's [ __ ] weird
about this
now it turned out as I said that this
was not an isolated incident by any
stretch of the imagination
during the 1980s there were several
dozen cases of mostly Southeast Asian
males teenagers and young men who died
for unknown reasons in their sleep
during the 1980s like a self-induced
astral projection that they didn't come
back they didn't come back something
like that and like I said I like [ __ ]
now some evidently animals can get so
stressed out that they die for without
any medical cause oh it's like stress
you might for sure achilles kills them
it just seems really weird how this one
this particular malady seems to
disproportionately target
young men of the Hmong ethnic group
usually from Laos and they are usually
refugees that because so what ended up
happening because the Hmong were fight
were fighting with the u.s. against the
North Vietnamese during the Vietnam War
and they're mostly from Laos as I said
now after the war was over the Laotian
government considered them traitors
because they had worked with the US so a
lot of them were forced to flee their
homeland so a lot of them went to
Thailand but a lot of them came to the
United States as well you know so there
were there were a whole but like 30,000
like soldiers fought with the US so they
started moving here like after the
Vietnam War like 1975 1976 now there was
a pretty high rate of poverty among this
particular ethnic group after they moved
but then this then there also started to
be this mysterious thing where they were
just dying in their sleep and these like
I said there were mostly teenage 20s 30s
males almost always in perfectly fine
physical health and they would almost
inevitably just like die in their sleep
for what seemed to be no reason at all
that's weird because there's always this
story you know I guess I got it from my
dad I don't know if this is a damn
Mississippi story or what we always
assumed that if you die in your sleep
dream he would die in reality yeah I've
heard that but I don't know where that
came from because I've been killed in my
dreams and I survived it I could yeah my
dad yeah so we don't know where that
story came from I've been falling off
top of building I screamed all the way
down here talking about like a 30 floor
drop and I dropped it you know I fell
all 30 stories hit and then bounced wake
up I woke up deer in the boughs yeah but
no hit and bounce there was about 15
feet back up in the air during the
bounce that I woke up most time you wake
up before you hit the ground yeah most
of the time
I didn't on that one I've also had
dreams where people just been
machine-gunned at close range feel the
bullets going through me and everything
yeah and didn't die I think that's a
pretty common cuz I've heard that too
that if you die in your sleep you die in
real life yeah
and that's kind of where I always you
know before I knew about this weird
thing that's kind of where I always
thought he got the idea for a nightmare
and I'm sure it because I'm like oh I
thought that was a pretty common
misconception that like if you died in
your sleep you die okay I first heard it
from my dad and as soon as he said it he
said it was [ __ ] I'm going yeah it's
[ __ ] because I'm sure I had been
killed in my dream yeah he mentioned it
I had already been killed in my dreams
yeah I've had been grabbed by the back
of the neck by a bear and just slung
around like a rag doll and feel my head
pop off or I actually felt the body pop
off my head about bears still a head to
head and I saw the body go fly oh [ __ ]
yeah and I didn't die
yeah of course not I'm still pretty
weird and I did die but I guess the
whole time I watched it happened you
know I remember I got killed and dream
getting trampled but I was running
across a stream there's a whole herd of
horses behind me enough slipped and fell
in the stream and now all his horses
trampled me remember seeing looking up
in the water and seen those hooves
coming down through the surface of the
water crushing me hmm yeah I could feel
them you know and I was dead you know
yeah and you're getting beat to death
please down all these verbs these horses
running over me yeah it's really weird
how realistic dreams
yeah I thought it was real man because I
but it doesn't kill you well now
obviously yeah well somebody say that
well you didn't really die in that dream
you just you know what I mean well it
just seems like that seems like
nitpicking at this point I mean if you
said you died and you're hearing how
they gonna prove otherwise
really I didn't dream that I got killed
and then went to heaven maybe that's
what they're talking about
yeah I don't know I don't know a lot of
times either the dream changes or or or
you wake up usually I wake up yeah most
people do I think as it
I think from everybody I've talked to
about dreams and [ __ ] like that
I do feel like most of the time if you
if somebody's gonna stab you or
something like that your dream you
usually wake up for the happens because
it startles you yeah but not always I'm
pretty sure I've dream I've dreamed that
I've been murdered or zout these guys
tied it must have just been well that's
what I mean so yeah there's this whole
weird thing so there and you know like I
said there have been like dozens and
dozens of these like in the late 70s and
early 80s
like I don't know but like there was
this one guy he was only 47 perfectly
fine mental health that perfectly fine
physical health he was sleeping next to
his wife as you do and he was like kind
of crying in his sleep as if he was
having a nightmare and he also died and
then when they did like they did autopsy
post-mortem [ __ ] like that and they
couldn't find anything wrong that's
what's so weird about this so they've
been trying to figure out like what
could this be
like some you know some people in this
sounds very far-fetched but it's like
you know what else are you gonna do some
people have said well maybe it was like
a chemical nerve agent but it's just
like slow acting or something like that
they got in the battlefield or something
cuz like I said a lot of them were
refugees but you know what I mean like
that just seems to be yeah that's a faux
trained in that [ __ ] know that and yeah
like I said a lot of doctors said you
know no that's no way that's not how
nerve agents work but it's like you know
they're just grasping at straws to try
to find some explanation because when
they have done you know autopsies on
these men that have died and they said
you know if it was something like more
like a physical cause or like a chemical
cause or something like that you think
it would affect the women as well
because they were also there they were
also refugees and everything like that
but it's so good she'll only be checking
yet and it and it really seems it does
affect other people now and again but it
affects this particular population well
so you think to a much greater degree or
anything in that culture that that that
allows for this thank you there is like
a spiritual belief like some of them
have said that because they left Laos
that the spirits of their ancestors were
punishing
like that they had a belief about that
that's about as hokey is Mississippi
story if you get killed you dreaming
that's what I mean it's like but but
like I said they're really kind of
getting to the point where [ __ ] is
something biological maybe there was
something in selective breeding somehow
that that that racial group in Laos
somehow they didn't inherit some kind of
safety mechanism in their brains or
something yeah where if they had some
kind of a real traumatic shock inside a
dream that it shut down the damn brain
yeah not a weird collapse I mean and
maybe it's just something they don't
look because there is actually they did
they did actually give this illness a
name later on it's called ace what go
ahead
it's called sons sudden unexplained
nocturnal death syndrome like I said it
does affect other people but it
disproportionately affects this
particular ethnic group okay remember
when I was in the Army and I had those
out-of-body experiences yeah maybe
that's what this is except they don't
it's organic type out-of-body experience
and because of their maybe they have
some religious beliefs that allows them
to go exteriorize easily and then they
just tune out they go off into a higher
dimension then never came back because I
told you I kind of had a feeling like I
wanted to gravitate up towards some kind
of higher frequency of conscious
existence which would have been kind of
like a heaven kind of like a going away
it didn't happen though yeah but maybe
they did but maybe but you I mean you've
said to me that you felt like you could
have just kept going I could've dad just
kept going but and then had you got not
just kept going that maybe I would have
died yeah but I kind of felt like I kind
of had like I built in a kind of like a
built-in resistance to doing that
yeah but maybe they didn't maybe because
of their religion and then they had been
through that now that they were out of
body that they said [ __ ] I can't go back
I'm dead so you and they just took also
it gave them what they asked for
yeah maybe it's just this one particular
like perfect storm of fact if it had
have been some kind of self induced
out-of-body experience you know cuz the
kid one kid said he was afraid to go to
sleep because he would never wake up
right he thought he'd be attacked in his
sleep and he would never wake up maybe
he made that happen yeah you know I mean
yeah cause maybe your self fulfilling
prophecy fulfilling prophecy he fell
asleep had a dream the dream was so
traumatic that it made an out-of-body
experience he says I'm dead just like I
thought it was gonna happen I'm dead I
gotta go gotta go to heaven or whatever
and Shh
that kind of [ __ ] bothers me because
self-induced you know well yeah and I've
read a lot about that kind of stuff like
self induced illnesses and so you know
people that get like [ __ ] stigmata
and [ __ ] like that and they think that
some people can actually like do that
just by thinking about answers and it's
just like that freaks me out because
it's like what if I was just like
hanging out one day and I accidentally
like thought something really horrible
I'm like what if I did it it's kind of
like now that's it now I'm worried about
that kind of like sometimes if I think I
got something in my eye I might rub it
and I'll feel like there's something
good there's some in your eyes it's
worse and worse yeah and there's nothing
in your eye yeah okay so it might have
been something like that they're afraid
they're gonna die when they go to sleep
and they actually do they build
themselves up is there's almost like a
frenzy here and I mean and it's like
self-hypnosis yeah and then when they
die that happens they have an OBE and it
becomes NDE and a de dos de it goes
death experience yeah that's the thing
it suggests we're very powerful
maybe that's what an animal does when
it's under a lot of stress it just
checks out yeah the soul just leaves it
true really yeah I mean it's not crazy
it's just I mean the weirdest thing
about it was that it just
disproportionately like attacked this
particular set of people like I said it
does happen to other people occasionally
but it just seems to like they had this
thing called I think it's called so I
think is what it was called and it's
something that you know veterinarians
and and people who are in this wall just
know about
game animals like zebras and deer and
stuff that you know four-legged animals
with horns that tend to get eaten kind
of have they've noticed that when a
bunch of lions of piled on them you know
glad to start eating them alive yeah and
if you look at their eyes their eyes
roll back into their head they're not
even hardly struggle and evidently they
did some kind of test on the EKGs on
animals when they were feeding them to
lions and their brainwave activities
kind of go flat before they're dead it's
kind of like they put themselves into
like a trance it's like denial that way
they don't have to they don't have to
bear the agony of beating being eaten
alive it's kind of like well make it
defense max like a defense mechanism I
mean it seems like something called
brain would evolve to do yeah and I
think it's called so I think long time
since I've heard like you said it might
that might be something similar going on
here there's something like that there's
some humans can't activate a mode like
that where they just check out yeah to
avoid pain of being eaten alive by
something yeah and in most humans its
vestigial yeah you know thousand
Cambodia in all those places you know me
that's jungle you know they're not that
for that lifestyle isn't that far
removed from nature so maybe some of
them still have that ability yeah of you
know tens of thousands of years ago you
could check out if you were getting
eaten by a tiger yeah cuz they're Tigers
they're Tigers eat a humanoid shape
dance you know humans just a big monkey
yeah especially to a tiger so maybe
their ancestors were still regularly
being eaten by Tigers or something in
the past five thousand they had that
some of they might still have that and
now when they are put under like that's
like a lot of stress like the war and
then like having to being completely
transplanted to an alien culture and
like you think it's not going well there
and then they can just flip the wrong
internal switch and have a [ __ ]
near-death experience that they don't
ever come back from yeah you gotta get a
death experience that's the Tom Ross
explanation well it sounds like it's a
lot more [ __ ] feasible than
nerve leak leading which like I said
every medical professionals like yeah no
that's not how that works human mind is
very powerful and they don't know much
about consciousness consciousness is
some kind of quantum computation there
when they're making these quantum
computers they're trying to make these
quantum AI supercomputers yeah that's
gonna that's probably gonna make a
difference between digital because
what's happening with a digital computer
it's just computation you know I mean
computation is not enough to to have an
emergent property like consciousness
because if that was the case it'd be
like it was in Terminator the Skynet
would it would have become conscious in
other words the internet would be
conscious yeah cuz that's a bunch of
computation that's what but it's not
conscious you're gonna need something
that's not digital it's gonna have to be
quantum there's some evidently you know
Stuart Hameroff and those guys say that
the the mind and the brain have it are
doing things with does microtubules that
kind of look like a quantum computation
yeah which that opens up a whole new
ballgame so if you have if your brain as
it has if you get those little neurons
have those microtubules and each one of
them's kind of like a kind of like a
warm temperature quantum processor
that's gonna add a whole lot more you
know what I mean
computational ability than just damn
zeros and ones and you know neurons
firing and not firing so that's probably
it's some consciousness is very
complicated and out I mean and biology
can cause it yeah I guess biology can
cause it to stop to which like I said
now I'm kind of like worried about it
yeah because what if I what if you like
think about it too are you thinking
about too hard and all the sudden you
think yourself out of your body
yeah you just vanish great another thing
for me to worry about yeah I guess
something like that I'm well they can't
find another explanation like Centers
for Disease Control have been studying
this shit's like everybody was studying
in this [ __ ] and they can't find any
obvious physical cause you know what I
mean it's gonna be something like OBE
out-of-body experience
and NDE so it's gonna be like astral
projection yeah they actually projected
out of there he didn't come back I guess
yeah it's just like that's a freaky case
but yeah in case you guys didn't know
Nightmare on Elm Street based on that
[ __ ] which is a real thing and they
don't know what causes it
sleep tight right now we're gonna talk
about the third case yeah which was the
base if you didn't notice cuz I said
that no dennis has been awfully quiet on
this show there's been quiet I remember
this thing yeah I just got this our
friend Laurie gave this to me for my
birthday
she's the one that went and saw the show
with us yeah yeah because she knows how
much I love Edgar Allen Poe
yeah that's some Poe action and actually
this kind of fits in because we didn't
on top of the elements yeah it was
scientific issues real science [ __ ] we
got all the [ __ ] like I said this
actually kind of goes with our last case
The Watcher because the movie that they
made about the watcher the killer was
named or the stalker was named the raven
in it so alright I didn't even realize
until you just put it up there that kind
of went together however the case we
were talking about right now is the real
and sort of well-known legend or not
really legend cuz shit's it happened
they're just not really entirely sure
what did it yeah this was the basis of
the 2001 movie Brotherhood of the wolf
among many things like I said it's a
good movie if you haven't seen it check
it out this is the story of the beast of
chef Odette
yeah the mysterious [ __ ] you know I like
animals yeah hot and stuff this involves
a hotter guy trying to look at this damn
werewolf
well everybody was like yeah everybody's
hand for the King brought this guy on
here who was the big badass to go fight
hunt this thing down it was killing all
these people and if I remember correctly
the story he does kill it and then they
have it stuffed but nobody knows what it
is that I don't know but like it's a
legend baby yeah now people as far as I
know people did die I don't think this
is like entirely made up or anything
like that they're just not entirely sure
what it was that did it or like if it
was just wolves just like regular wolves
happening to be I don't believe this
will
wolf stories because even wolves in the
wild are not not aggressive yeah I mean
maybe they were back then but I don't
think so it's just dogs yeah and it'd be
I think it'd be tough to get a pack of
wolves to attack you yeah I mean it did
happen in Europe particularly you know
in the 15 16th century stuff like that
but not to this extent I mean this seems
like quite a lot of people that were
attacked in a pretty small a relatively
small area the medieval 's were anti
animal in the extreme I mean they just
like to kill [ __ ] and they would say
well we killed it because it was
dangerous
yeah miss it wasn't dangerous and I mean
bringing bears aren't dangerous
you got bears in damp backyard yeah no
they'll run from humans mostly wolves
will too so I just I don't think this
was wolves yeah I I have my suspicions
about what it might have been but you
know it was either a serial killer or
some kind of dangerous foreign animal
yeah so the story of the Beast of
Gevaudan
this is the name given to either a
single animal or a bunch of animals not
sure if it was more than one that
happened to kind of terrorize this one
province called Chavo Dom in
south-central France in the years 1764
to 1767 so this was like not a big area
was about a 50 50 square mile area 1560s
yeah this is a lot later than I thought
it was may am remember in another case
maybe but I mean this is the most famous
one okay case I was thinking how my
thought was the 1500 1700 people knew
better yeah who were supposedly knew
better
we'll see yeah I mean they knew a lot
about animals in the 70s now a lot of
the descriptions that people gave
because some people did survive and some
people did see other people get killed
said that it looked kind of like a wolf
or a wolf dog hybrid but it was like
much bigger than a regular wolf now
where there were some other descriptions
to that kind of maybe could have
suggested something else but you know a
wolf dog Hagrid but bigger yeah
so a lot of the victims that were found
had their throats torn out some of them
were also partially eaten the sources
differ on how many victims there were
some sources say that the animals killed
between sixty and a hundred adults and
children and injured about thirty
whereas some say there were more than
200 attacks and that a hundred and
thirteen people died and forty nine
people were injured of those about a
hundred of them were also partially
eaten as well over what period of time
three years that's a lot of killing yeah
well yeah that's why people are still
talking about this [ __ ] and they're
saying this is one animal or a group of
animals the witnesses are only report
and one though at a time
yeah ones that long far as I know ones
they're alive yeah I'm already smelling
[ __ ] a pack of animals is hard to
hide yeah especially aggressive ones all
right
a solitary animal to attack 100 people
and kill how many out of the hundred
actually killed 100 out of 300 210
attacks to our attention
113 deaths in three years in three years
yeah in this one like 50 miles you know
if you square mile radius that's not a
dog that's not a wolf you know I mean
that's something that's if that's one
animal doing that that's a very
aggressive animal no [ __ ] that's a lot
of people yeah that's a lot of balls
most animals won't attack people yeah
well like I said people don't like
they're still talking to people are not
the normal prey yeah so if you could
come at me telling me this is a wolf I
must say you're a liar well I don't know
people like some people just said it
looked like a wolf because that's the
closest thing that actually yeah that's
how they're describing it they probably
have never been to a zoo they've never
seen a zoology book it's a four-legged
animal with fur on and teeth that's what
they're saying yeah kind of dog shaped
you that might be a and they're saying
it's bigger than a dog yeah most of them
did that I am some kind of maybe one day
have recognized the tiger
hard to say in France during that time
here and they said would they have known
what a tiger actually looked like the
average person you know I don't know or
a hyena now a couple people at the time
did say hyena so how does a hyena gonna
get there from Africa and hyenas don't
generally get that big that big and only
like no I understand that
though the females are kind of
aggressive but they're not real
aggressive towards human beings yeah
it's almost kind of like you'd have to
train an animal to do this I don't know
man I'm oh I'm I'm thinking there's some
kind of misunderstanding
I don't know this has got to be a
mixture of a couple different things it
very well maybe it's too many people
yeah so the the stories around us
surrounding the Beast of Gevaudan they
think that this actually might be where
a lot of like commonly seen werewolf
chirps come from because one of the
stories is that the hunter that actually
eventually ended up killing the Beast
because a bunch of wolves and other
animals were killed like leading up to
but then like the attacks kept going
going so you know the one the one animal
that they killed and then the attacks
stopped afterward who's killed by a
hunter named Jean austell Jos tell the
story said that he had actually killed
the thing with a bullet that he had
forged out of silver so they think that
that's where the silver bullet thing for
werewolves might have come from just
from from descriptions of that now even
though as I said descriptions of what
the Beast looked like are kind of varied
in general they said it looked like a
wolf although some people said it was as
big as a calf some said it was as big as
an elephant they said it had a doglike
head with small straight ears that stuck
straight up a little bit like horns that
had a wide chest some people said that
it was as wide as like a horse's chest
they said it had a really big mouth with
really big canine teeth now the only
thing that was not wolf like was they
said that the fur was reddish or russet
in coal
that's a target and that it had know
that it had like um like a black streak
on its back like or like a black stripe
going down its back which sounds like a
hyena but like I said hyenas don't
usually get that big now the first
recorded death was a girl named Jean
Boulais she was 14 years old many of the
victims that should be noted were women
and children and a lot of them were
shepherds they were like out in the
fields like guarding the Sheep or
whatever so she was killed while she was
out watching her sleep as I said
watching her sheep she was 14 years old
so these these killings just kept like
continuing through 1764 a lot of the
women and children a lot of them
shepherds the the killings were so
egregious that I mean even though this
was kind of a rural area they ended up
getting like a lot of widespread play
around France partly because the media
at the time because the King Louie the
15th at the time was you know [ __ ]
wasn't going so good in France and so he
kind of had a moratorium on printing
political stories in the newspaper so
newspapers to sell copies you know we're
looking for other like salacious stories
or like crazy stories to kind of put out
there and get people to buy their papers
so you know these series of attacks in
this kind of like rural area was kind of
big news and it kind of like got all
over the country at that point so the so
the stuff starts going on and it went on
for such a long time and it you know got
to such a big frenzy in the media that a
bunch of like local aristocrats and
officials and stuff like that started to
you know try and go and do something
about the problem so the first time they
go out they actually raised like a
volunteer army of like 30,000 guys and
they kind of went out there to try to
look for this thing they put down poison
bait they had they even did [ __ ] like
they had some of the soldiers like dress
up as like peasant women like and say
that was sheep and stuff like that like
to see if they could like Laura the
beasts and the like attacking them and
[ __ ] like that they put out like a big
ward it was like a year's salary and
[ __ ] like that for anybody they could
unit dick it anybody could kill it so
you know so there were all these stories
to about they think that there might
have been and the reason why it took
such hold in the public imagination I
mean other than it obviously being like
a horrifying story which you know
everybody loves to read about sadly
enough but they think because France
hadn't been doing very well in the war
you know they'd had like a lot of
setbacks and all this other kind of
stuff so they thought that maybe there
was something of this was something
everybody could kind of like rally
around like all the men could go and
like we can go be heroes and we can go
kill these animals and also it was a
little bit it seemed like they were kind
of because a lot of stories came out to
where they were kind of like lauding the
peasantry particularly peasants who like
fought back against the animals because
some people did like some peasants like
got attacked by the animal like actually
be a but were able to fight it off there
was this one kid named Jacques porta FA
and him and some of his little friends
were out in a meadow like with their
cattle and they got attacked by the
beasts and it wasn't a pact it was a
single animal and they actually managed
to fend it off like with their little
pikes or whatever now because because of
that he ended up getting him and all his
little friends ended up getting like a
monetary reward and that kid and ended
up actually getting educated at the
Kings it's expense because they were
like he was such a hero for like
fighting off the fighting off the animal
now there was another little girl
actually
Marysia on valet she was attacked on
August 11th 1765 and she actually fought
the Beast off and actually heard it and
she got called the maiden of Javad on
and they actually made a statue of her
and it is still there in a town in
southern France now as I said even
though descriptions varied most people
refer to it as a wolf but like I said
that's not wolf behavior that's not yeah
and a lot of people have kind of pointed
that out and like I said some people
described it
another thing that I forgot to mention
to was that it didn't have a wolf-like
tail it had more people that described
as Hale said it was kind of like long
and thin more like a lion's tail that's
what I was thinking this is a cat and
that's something that I was watching I
was watching a like a historian on
YouTube who was talking about this case
and he said that it definitely sounded
more like cat behavior they said because
wolves they're not stealthy well and
he's like when wolves attack and wolves
do attack people he's like I'm not
saying that but they usually attack in a
pack they usually just tuck their teeth
not with their claws and a lot of these
victims were clawed like a like a big
cat would do yeah and this is an ambush
by predators yes some sneak enough
solitary with stealth it it how you know
won't do that I ain't no animal no
they're not stealthy they're loud yeah
you know I mean they're loud and you
know kid they don't even hide right you
know I mean if it was a if it was
something like a hyena that I could walk
right down the middle of a town there
yeah they don't have that instinct in
them but not a cat a cat will scar
around and zero in on you yes and
getting close on it it's it's some kind
of a mundane cat that a European at that
time couldn't recognize this it has been
a hybrid kind of like unusual might have
been or something might have been like
part tiger and part mountain lion yeah
they probably would have never
recognized what that was yeah because if
it was sufficiently weird yeah and kind
of kind of rot kind of reddish with a
strike going down its back yeah
conceivably that maybe if you took
something like a mountain lion and a
tiger and bred it or a lion and it
aligned they knew it Lions were yeah
okay maybe you take a lion and a
mountain lion and crossbreed it because
you know you can have ligers and Tiger
ons and uh-huh stuff there weren't many
of these big cats in captivity in Europe
at that time they were in menageries and
stuff like wealthy people had them that
was kind of a thing so it might be
something where a wealthy person has a
damn mountain lion that came
the New World and they cross it with an
African cat because that's what they
have yeah and that's what comes out like
he's a cat you're a cat get in there and
there's some kind of weird offspring and
it gets out yeah yeah it's gonna be
something like that
and even at the time that all of this
was going on a few people did make that
that they thought that it wasn't maybe
not straight up a lion but that it was
something else crossed with a lion yeah
and whoever did it got out of some rich
guy's collection that's what I'm
thinking and he's not gonna fess up
because there's two you know two hundred
people that are a hundred people dead
right he's gonna he's gonna go our all I
know I would never do such a thing I
wouldn't keep such large dangerous
animals yeah and some like that could
survive on extended periods eating
people oh yeah yeah because that's I
kind of close to its prey yeah closest
in size total to what it would eat and I
mean if like some poor little woman or
kid is just standing out there with
their cattle or their sheep or whatever
and that big little kitty like skulk
spine is like oh that looks delicious
right there in in that situation back
then it might have been easier to go
after people than then add in damn
flocks sheep yeah because the flocks
might have been better guarded by dogs
and stuff then then the little girl was
well yeah so you know I mean though the
cat jumps on that little girl tries to
drag her off yeah
and they did in some cases yeah and I'm
there sufficiently stealthy enough to
kind of evade detection for three years
yeah dude they could do this that's what
I was thinking and like when I was
watching this historian that was talking
about it um you know he's like obviously
we don't know what it is nowadays but he
seemed to lean toward the same thing
he's like yeah he thought it was maybe a
juvenile line he's like because he's
like maybe peasants would recognize a
lion with a mainly the main but not but
if it didn't have a mane or if it had
been cross bred with something else then
they might not immediately recognize it
because it wouldn't be an animal you
would reckon it's gonna be something
that if a modern person saw it you'd
know what it was yeah I mean cuz it had
to be something cuz all these [ __ ]
people died right I don't think this was
you know yeah it might have been
exaggerated because as the story went on
because it was such a media
sation you know obviously crazy details
got laid later on like oh the animal
could walk on a time feed and it's like
we shot it and nothing happened like it
could repel bullets and like it she had
fire eyes and [ __ ] like that two of the
things of the description kind of stood
out to me that it had a broad chest yeah
and then it was about the size of calf
and they also said that it leaped like
that it could leap early do you know
what has brought about that like no no
chest I'm not lying
yeah mountain lions are kind of short
and stocky as far as cats go they don't
have very long legs
yeah so they kind of have kind of a
let's see when they're young so they
kind of have that broad chest almost a
human sized chest on them really with
kind of like short legs almost like a
Datsun yeah you know but they have a cat
head but they don't have a Mane so maybe
a person who doesn't never seen a
mountain lion might not recognize that
as a lie because they never mane yeah
and they're describing that same tail
and a mountain lion does kind of have
ears like that yeah okay kind of stick
that and another good talking and
another thing that I was thinking too is
that and you see this nowadays was like
I said with the lion and tiger hybrids
that they tend to be much larger than
either lions or Tigers it might have
just been a straight up mountain lion
because this is the 1760s yeah there
were all kinds of mountain lions in the
United States trapped and sold and stuff
you know and it's only only a matter of
time for somebody's gonna sell one to a
European Noble yeah you know I mean from
the new world yeah you could get you
could get mountain lions from the United
States well yeah of course you could get
pretty much anything you get a buffalo I
mean if you're rich and yeah if you're
rich alone in Richmond if you guineas
and they just love all that exotic yeah
shipped me one of those give me one of
them American bison you know man they
could do that yeah it's just that the
peasants regular people wouldn't wait
you would never see that you don't see
them like in your day to day life it's
not like they have the [ __ ] Internet
or I think it's worthy I think is what
it was I think was a Booma yeah it's
very possible and like I said this guy I
was talking to he seemed to lean toward
that - he's
I think it was some kind of big cat
there's some kind of hybrid cattle just
like I Bank a poor man a mountain lion
is the same thing things just different
different title for the dis ain't basic
thing yeah I think I think I think I
think it's interchangeable
I met weirder code you know Rob here in
the United States we're gonna look at
something like that called a mountain
lion yeah I think I think a puma is the
same though that might be a Central
American version of it yeah I'm not sure
there might be a slight definitely my
difference that's what they talk like
they were something like a puma yeah but
so as I said the killings continue so
they keep sending like bands apart you
know you get like all these hunters like
I'd have killed twelve hundred wolves
I'm gonna go out there and get it
because like I said there was a massive
reward so September 19 1765 rather you
know a couple big-game hunters went out
there and actually shot and killed a
very large wolf sent the body to
Versailles got a reward from King Louis
the 15th and as far as the royalty was
concerned that was the end of the
battery up that was it all over except
two months later attack started again
and then for the next 18 months there
were around 30 to 35 more fatalities
during that time period but since the
king had already paid out the reward and
already said hey we already got this big
giant wolf that it was there just like
too bad so sad we're not gonna help you
anymore because this must be some other
[ __ ] and we don't want to get involved
it makes sense that it was a poem or a
mountain lion because in that place in
time there weren't very many wild
animals all your animals are in some
kind of damn hurt yeah you know I mean
so so they would have been and so a poem
Upen in it would be and it would have
been in a jam because if they're not in
the apartment in that in in the
environment it's supposed to be in it
wouldn't have any choice but to go after
little kids yeah that's what it would do
but so since they weren't getting any
help from the king anymore the locals
started banding together and decided to
send out their own hunting parties and
[ __ ] like that
so Jean chasse tell who I said who as I
said was the guy that's like credited
with killing the Beast of jihad on even
though you know whatever he actually got
out
and using reportedly a silver bullet he
shot another very large wolf now even
though I suspect that this was not the
Beast
the attacks did stop after this
particular animal was killed so everyone
thought oh well that guy got it and he
is the guy that's credited with killing
the Beast of jebediah
even though like I said I'm very much
doubt that it was a ball so they never
recovered a body so as far as I know
because there's still debate about what
that animal was I mean you know people
assumed at the time oh well because this
big wolfy shot and then the attack
stopped after that like I'm free of me
that doesn't mean anything I mean
coincidentally the animal could have
died out so God died on its own my three
you know maybe it only lasted three
years because it maybe it wasn't in his
natural habitat yeah it just slowly
starved to death wasn't getting enough
food or you know it got stuck in
something and died you know ran up
something yeah ran down in a damn
drainage pipe never and it was you know
I couldn't get back out there's all
kinds of stuff it was in a place where
it didn't belong yeah and it didn't have
its normal food and it had it been
raised in captivity it wouldn't have
very many survival skills and maybe it
didn't do real wells in the European
winters there's all kinds of factors
that's what I mean I kind of suspect so
like I said you know to this day there's
still a lot of you know some people said
oh it was like you know some people that
that point to like maybe it was a wolf
or wolves like larger-than-average said
you know there were a lot of wolf
attacks in other parts of france like
during this period you know begin like
from the 16th century to the 19th
century wolves killed about 9,000 people
in that in france so wolves killed 9,000
people yeah kind of wolves they deal
very angry and hungry people let
themselves get attacked by dogs i I mean
you have to think that's their bollocks
that's over like 300 years
oh that's about 300 years I mean still a
lot but it's the 300 years I gotta be
taking off a week in entire country well
that's what this one particular thing
was doing however most modern scholars
tend to believe that it was a lion that
escaped from a menagerie or some kind of
is a big cat some kind of unusual hybrid
of a cat
there were even this is very funny but
there were actually rumors that Jean
Ches tell the guy that ended up killing
quote-unquote the beast of jihad on that
it was his animal he had actually
trained it to kill people so he could go
out there and be a badass and like
[ __ ] chillin stuff which seems a tad
perfect yes that wants and make money
then he'd do it regularly a behavior he
would be appearing at all these [ __ ]
different sites of where animals are
attacking people besides that's [ __ ]
yeah you can't train attack you can't
train an animal attack people let it go
and then reclaim it later yeah I just
once that thing's gone it's doing its
own thing it's understand that seems
like an inevitable story that's kind of
something that's gonna come up about
that and it's like there were even
stories that because like I said since
[ __ ] got exaggerated later on in some
people's I know I shot it and it didn't
kill it and some people said though that
somebody oh did it at war was wearing
like some kind of armor like boar skin
or something like that it's like I said
it seems a little guarantee this is a
this is a North American mountain lion
or some kind of central South American
Puma you had guys and porridge come on
Spain that were already tied up with
colonies going all all down Central and
South America that thing could have come
from anywhere I could have been a Jaguar
yeah you know now there was a shot like
that there was a show in 2009 on the
History Channel
and it was called the real Wolfman I
guess it was one of those like real live
monster shows and they put forth the
theory that it might have been a striped
hyena which is a long-haired hi and
they're extinct now and I guess they're
bigger than other regular hyenas so
they're speculating that maybe it was
that or maybe it was some other like
holdover that are at stake now er there
wasn't that many of them or more I think
of it the more moose heads cat I kind of
feel like it's mostly just from the tail
and the way that they said a lot of the
way I wanted that it jumped like that it
could jump really far yeah which not so
much a wolf thing hyenas are doglike
pack hunters yeah they're not stealthy
yeah you know and they don't hunt that
way yeah and they kind of hunt the way a
dog does it just walk around till you
see something and then you start yelling
at it and chasing it you know
not they usually have to to get a kill
they usually have to be working it up in
a big pack as a team they're not an
effective solitaire oh yeah because they
have to kind of lay there they use their
little friends to like get them all
they're not station they're not skilled
solitary hunters not like a cat yeah a
cat could go out on its on its own or
regularly feed itself and in this one
evidently was for three years but when
an animal's fail they don't fail all at
once they fail slowly over a period of
years because each year they they just
can't quite get the same amount of
calories that they had the year before
and it's and this so they get a little
weaker each year and then the rats say
they just can't make it anymore
well on the thing too is that if this
was indeed a lion or another kind of
hybrid cat that escaped from a menagerie
then it wouldn't have had any other
animals in the vicinity to mate with or
anything like that so it would have been
all alone which usually isn't a huge
problem for particular types of cats but
in the 70s line won't continue 1760s
Frances ball just a bunch of farms yeah
so you know it would it would have been
forced to feed off of those farms yeah
and you know if they couldn't get two
animals they'd get at the children and
it was probably getting the animals too
but the epidemic PM that was getting
blamed on wolves and older fox and other
stuff so you know it wasn't being
attributed to this beast
it just went after whatever it could get
and if it was people then he could do
that too yeah but like I said some
people drove it off and that checks out
with a big cat also some like a boom or
a mountain lion this you not tell my
something huge like a tiger it's fierce
you know a couple little kids with
sticks could drive that off well yeah I
guess it would be because predators
don't want to get hurt even a minor
injury could end your life well yeah
because they'll starve you're starving
you can't eat so that's what it was I'm
just gonna come out and say Tom Ross has
solved it this is some kind of [ __ ]
mountain line yeah but like I said it
was a new world cat
not African I bet it was it was
something that wouldn't have been
immediately recognized the African stuff
but I think stuff from from the Americas
they probably would have would have been
more exotic more exotic to them and like
I said it could have been a hybrid too
so close quote a ban but unlikely I
think more likely that it was just a
straight-up out lion yeah something that
if we saw it we go yeah sonic animal you
know we look at it good man so [ __ ]
about why true but yeah so like I said
there's been tons of [ __ ] there's
other movies made about this one too but
like I said probably the best known one
is Brotherhood of the wolf is really
good I mean the movie Brotherhood of the
wolf the Beast is actually a lion but it
has armor on yeah like somebody's using
it to like yeah because it's a movie but
it is a lion in the movie yeah so like I
said you're not that wasn't real life
yeah it probably was so like I said a
lot of people have said that all right
so we've gotten more than past the
halfway point probably so we are going
to take a break right now and when we
come back we will do two more cases
which are both very fascinating we will
be talking about the case behind The
Hills Have Eyes and also the case behind
The Watcher yeah which I'm kind of
excited about talking about that one cuz
this is a weird [ __ ] case yeah
alright so we will be back in just a few
minutes
you love true crime
I love true crime and I've spent the
last three years compiling a series of
the most intriguing unsolved murders of
the 20th century it's called the
faceless villain and volume three is
available now featuring such fascinating
cases as the Caddy murders the carry
babies case the Frog Boys the al-qasr
murders and the inokashira park
dismemberment incident the faithless
villain volume three is an involving
exploration of unsolved slang spanning
the years from 1980 to 1999 pick up your
copy and print or eBook formats on
Amazon or download the audiobook version
from audible.com and get ready for a
chilling journey through modern crime
history
what's up pretty princess yeah you are
so fluffy
you are so fluffy and pretty yes you are
you look all prim and proper yeah yeah
where did Pookie go there's hey hi baby
girl yeah
are you gonna go hang out with Beijing
I'm gonna go hang out with Beijing
you're just kind of looking at each
other like yeah look I'm just chilling
out this is really good because when we
first got baby cookie Beijing was not
happy about it yeah and she was always
hissing at her and beating up on her and
stuff but it looks like they've come to
a grudging acceptance now they kind of
like hang out - she still has is that
her sometimes if she gets in - yeah but
you know oh goodness
look at her role in your own
conspiratorial podcasts proudly presents
the strange realities conference injury
come join us for one day of
presentations on the paranormal of live
music at night featuring Tim the knob
the rise and fall of the Flat Earth
theory
Joshua kuchen alien hybrid lore Joe
Damari pushing the limits of reality
guide Roswell 1947 what really happened
Timothy Ritter Pennsylvania Wildman and
added to the lineup Marc Anthony Wyatt
Cornish legends and UFO sighting Zach
Hunt's presentation of his book on
drought followed by a live recording at
the conspiratorial podcast more speakers
and music acts to be announced October
19 2019 si our nationís info at wwlp.com
$40 at the door 30 bucks presale
[Music]
all right we're back from the break ya
know what I did what doing that break I
went and I looked at the difference
doing a mountain lion a cougar and a
puma it's all the same it's all the same
animal
it's all North American mountain lion
and now that we're looking at pictures I
looked at him and dad looks like a dog
they do have big like pointing straight
up ears and they do have a like a little
bit of a doggie looking face yes it's
from certain angles specially to look at
straight at you and it got a wide chest
and that tail and they are kind of
reddish especially yeah you know the so
you know they change color throughout
the year and they do have black
highlights on them I could understand
how how a European in the 1700s who
maybe never seen one might not associate
it with it with a lion well you know and
some people have pointed out that
juvenile lions actually do have black
spots sometimes yeah so did it say it
had black spots well that usually said
it have black markings on its back like
a black stripe or it had low but it was
mostly red but it had like some yeah my
wives have that tuna yeah they have
things black and white highlights in the
ears and in the face that's what yeah
that that's a mountain lion that they
saw yeah apparently guarantee is
somebody from the Col and he said it
they got in some rich guys collection
and it got out when it started eating
people he kept his mouth shut
yeah he want to be held responsible for
it yeah what happened
got that [ __ ] solved all right so the
next case that we wanted to talk about
is the case that was the inspiration for
the West Craven film The Hills Have Eyes
yes good movie now as most people know
the Hills Have Eyes about a kind of clan
of backwoods savages inbred up in a
desert
stephane they kind of live in caves and
you know can touch people and cannibals
and stuff like that well this was
actually based on a real thing although
there is still debate over how much of
this story is exaggerated how much of it
is legend maybe it never happened maybe
it did happen but not to the extent that
the folklore has gone on to thing but
you know I'm not taking a stand on that
either way this is
the story of Sawney bean and his
cannibal clan now this happened in 16th
century Scotland Alexander
Sawney bean was said to be the head of a
45 person clan they were all his
relatives which we'll get into who lived
in a cave and are said to have killed
and eaten over a thousand people they
liked that long Pig I suppose so yeah
delicious I guess so well it's probably
easier than raising animals well
particularly when you live in a cave
yeah that's 44 other people you know now
the story of Sawney bean first appears
in something called the Newgate calendar
which was like kind of a true-crime kind
of catalogue from Newgate Prison in
London now like I said there's still
some debate over how much of this story
is true or false or whatever but in n
bruh nowadays and in Scotland it is you
know widely known folklore you can even
go to the suppose it's on e being cave
you know it's like a tourist destination
and [ __ ] like that so now according to
this story that was in the Newgate
calendar Alexandre Bean who would later
become known as Sawney for reasons that
have been lost to history was born in a
place called East Lothian during the
sixteenth century
his father was a hedge trimmer and ditch
digger and Alexander was at first going
to go into the family business but then
he decided that working for a living was
just not for him so he decides to leave
town and go out and find his own fortune
I suppose now story goes that he left
with this woman named Agnes Douglas also
known as black Agnes because she was
thought to be witch so the two of them
start robbing people yeah become high
women essentially just like ambushing
people in the street now or in the road
whatever they don't have streets really
bad men
so they supposedly Robin ate one victim
and then they move into this
hey've at this place called bene in the
head and any Scottish people I'm really
sorry if I'm like butchering these names
so they supposedly lived in this cave
which was two hundred yards deep and the
entrance of it like when the water came
up at high tide like you couldn't see
the entrance of it so they were kind of
like well-hidden like one night when the
tide was high they supposedly lived in
this cave for 25 years during this 25
years they produced six daughters and
eight sons and subsequently 18 grandsons
and 14 granddaughters so yo there was a
lot of incest and breeding
going on in this cave yeah which you
know like I said so this whole entire
family if you want to call it that how
they made their living was they would
ambush they would only come out at night
they didn't come out during the daytime
so the villagers around there were not
super aware of what was going on like
they knew people would go missing and
like you would get attacked in the road
and [ __ ] like that if you went out at
night but they didn't know that there
was like a whole clan of [ __ ]
cannibalistic serial killers living in
this [ __ ] cave cuz you couldn't
because they never came out in the
daytime so they would ambush anyone that
was like going down the road at night
take all their [ __ ] and then they would
kill them bring the bodies back to the
cave and then dismember them and eat
them now anytime there were leftovers
from because you know leftovers need to
take to work the next day
but this said they would pickle those
parts now story goes that they would
also take some of the parts that they
didn't want and they would like throw
them out of the water so they would wash
up on the beach so that people that went
missing like people would think that
animals had attacked them and [ __ ] like
that because they were trying to keep on
the DL you know as was stories coming
from where it was like a change its
first 60 it was 16th century that's 15
yeah and it first appeared like I said
it was the Newgate Prison like they had
like a yeah and they they were like a
thing had all these details in the
original story yeah bars I know about
the body parts wash it up and yeah this
sound implausible far as I know
implausible so far because usually if
there's some kind of wild tale of the
1500s from the fifteen hundreds there
have already been a bunch of
inconsistencies in it yeah and this
one's here this is it sounds so crazy
yeah
because he didn't want you wouldn't want
to eat all the body parts yeah not to
waste your time burying them he's gonna
throw them out in the water let the fish
get him yeah but it washes back up yeah
bones that you people see it yeah
whatever happened yeah and that is
before police stations and modern
investigative techniques and modern
investigation you know I mean you in the
1500 Zeke you probably get away with
that for a long time as he didn't know
where he you know I mean had that cave
not been found
yeah and those people not identified
well like I said they probably get away
there for a long time yeah 25 years
isn't a very long time under those
technological you know right sit under
that technological level that they had
back then yeah nowadays this you can get
you couldn't do this well yeah no one
person comes up missing then they
immediately try to backtrack and figure
out where this person vanished
yeah and if they start seeing a
consistent pattern they're like
something's in this areas kill these
people they find in that cave eventually
you know was musing modern investigative
techniques but not in the 1500 they
probably probably had a hard time
keeping track of the people that
vanished yeah yeah no no centralized
placed where they wrote all that down
and stored that information you know and
maybe some of the people like travelers
or like trans people that people got
vanished all the time by highway men and
stuff yeah that's what I mean that's why
it was so prevalent background because
there was like a lot of noise yeah just
kind of reminded me of stories of kind
of like those Indian guys through gi's
yeah kind of like foodie cults yeah go
ahead
but yeah so eventually so many
disappearances were happened in this
area that like a lot of the local
villages were like man we got to do
something about this so they started
like putting together you know little
search parties and everything like that
so they were posse see yeah so there
we're gonna go around and see what the
fout what the [ __ ] was going on
now they did actually kind of see the
cave entrance but they didn't really
think to look in there because they
thought it would look too small and they
didn't think any humans would live in
there or anything like that they did see
it but they didn't go in there at the
time so the interest of it was kind of
small yeah and it was like I said it you
couldn't really see it when the tide was
high cuz it was kind of like covered up
it was on the bank in the water well
it's kind of like it looked like from
the I'm not sure if like the one that is
you know in the legend that I saw in the
picture but it looked like it was kind
of like on a little bit of a cliff face
type of deal you know what I mean and it
didn't look very big alright I mean you
know what I mean so it's it's just that
you know they did note that that it was
there it's like oh there's like a little
cave entrance but I don't think anybody
could live in there so they didn't
really like search it to any great
degree now during this time period as
would normally happen there was like a
lot of panic you know some people were
lynched that later turned out to be
innocent people and you know so and
disappearances like continued to pay so
obviously they weren't getting the
people that were really doing it
some people even thought that some guy
like guys that kept ins in the area like
that maybe they were doing it because
like kind of a cop because that's like
the last time the people were seeing on
this particular in and then they
disappeared so they said maybe they're
knocking him off for their money and
like stealing all their [ __ ] and then
like burying him in the backyard that
would happen yeah that's what I mean so
there was like a lot of widespread like
belief that maybe that was going on now
it so happened that or the source so the
story goes that there was a married
couple and they were riding on one horse
and they were coming back from like a
fare that had been in the area and they
were set upon by some of the Sawney bean
clan now the clan ended up killing the
wife but the husband was able to fight
them off and at this stage that was
still like the fair wasn't that far in
the in the background you know that was
had they hadn't gone that far so a bunch
of other people that have been at the
fair like came to the guys aid and kind
of chased the clan a little bit down the
trail so then they kind of knew what cut
everybody whatever they were in a
carriage on a horse they were on a
running horse yeah and the Clannad
act him just barehanded or they had
weapons to say I don't know really I
don't know must have been kind of
barehanded
yeah maybe okay so um now so now that
they had like a guy that it survives an
attack word gets back to the king and
they decide that they're gonna go out
there and they get like a bunch of
bloodhounds and they're gonna find out
where these people are coming from so
the bloodhounds actually found the cave
as bloodhounds do wonder how they
tracked him down they must have given
some kind of sample to the dogs
maybe someones dropped left behind well
like I said that guy got attacked and
his wife got killed by them but they had
to have like some clothing or something
off his yeah well probably they took
some of the wife's clothing or something
yeah yeah because I don't think they
took the waist body because yeah that
show many people came and like yeah mom
maybe they tracked the wife so they
charged them
yeah that's what I'm saying so so the
bloodhounds apparently found the cave so
the group that had gone to look for them
they go in the cave and find all of
these people in there the Sawney bean
plan and then there's all kind of body
parts in there there's like pieces
hanging from the walls there's like
[ __ ] barrels with severed limbs in
there there's all kind of stolen [ __ ] so
it's like you know it's hard to see you
walk into the cave and there's like it's
not what it looks like I promise it's
like you're kind of caught ready and
it's 40 of them in there yeah I think
the 45 does how the story goes there's
49 of them living in this cave damn yeah
so with a bunch of yucky like severed
body parts I'm sure that smelled
fantastic yeah you know now will you say
we're eating it yeah
now there are two different versions of
what happened then the most common is
that the clan were all captured alive
that they didn't fight the authorities
or anything like that so they actually
took them all alive they chained them
all up they took them to toll booth jail
in Edinburgh then transferred them some
sources say lief some say Glasgow and
they didn't get a trial because
apparently the judge or whoever like
determined these things thought they
were so
human and that they did not merit a
trial so they were pretty much just
executed yeah now Sawney bean and all
the other men in the clan reportedly had
all of their genitalia cut off and then
thrown into the fire while they were
still alive
yeah they had their hands and feet
severed and were allowed to bleed out
yes they wanted them to so did that kind
of [ __ ] in the 1500 yeah didn't [ __ ]
around back then man they do they break
you on the wheel and stuff yeah or they
had you know they were just like [ __ ]
you you're evil we're gonna cut your
nuts off you know that's how they did it
yep that's how they roll back down and
all the female members of the clan they
made them watch them do that to the men
and then they burn them all at the stake
yeah the children also because some of
the members of the clan were still kids
yeah
there's also another version and I've
heard these two versions combined some
of the versions say to that they put
gunpowder like in the cave entrance and
then like just suffocated them all in
there although I've also heard that they
actually just blew up the cave like
after you don't I mean it sounds like
likely they'd brought them back and done
all that torture to him that's the most
common as well yeah because you know not
any other cases where they serial
killers and stuff that's usually what
they did to him yeah so I'm kind of
thinking that's what they would do if
they caught this big [ __ ] you know
[ __ ] thing um now as I said there's
some dispute over how much of this story
is true it should be noted that there
are a couple of older stories that are
kind of similar there's one called
Christie cleek that there's a story
called that and that actually came out
that was supposed to have happened in
1459 and that was like there was a thief
and his wife and kids and they lived in
a cave and they you know would capture
people and eat them and when they were
caught because I think they all got
executed they the daughter they actually
left her alive she was 12 years old and
they asked her
what the deal was like why her family
would do that and she said I tell you
this is a quote I tell you that if you
did but know how pleasant the taste of
man's flesh was none of you all would
forbear to eat it saying humans are so
[ __ ] delicious they would do the same
thing there was only meat she knew about
the only meat there right yeah so some
people are thinking that maybe the
Sawney bean tail is just maybe like a
retelling of this like maybe it's like
an urban legend
and you know some have said that oh
maybe it was like anti Scots propaganda
but then some people pointed out they're
like well it appeared in the new gay
calendar which also had [ __ ] about
English criminals in there too so it
wasn't like the English is picking on
the Scots which they did do yeah but you
know it's like if they just wanted to
pick on the Scots then you know they
would there were lots of stories that
like this this sound just like this that
I'm just pretty sure it was going on
yeah I think it was in the 1400 1500 had
the guy who thought he was a werewolf
going around eating every girl he saw
yeah and the way he would describe it
and everything he will he's a serial
killer
yeah and he was living with his sister
and an old abandoned house for God and
out in the damp forest and they had kids
together and that court kind of came to
that same conclusion that these are
subhumans yeah I think if you were badly
inbred they just killed you which that
probably that's what they did I think to
his kids too
yeah they were like Weymouth they're
brother and sister and then they got
where these kids come from you know so
they just they when they pass judgment
on them there wasn't like you said I
don't even think there was a trial it
was just kind of passed judgment yeah
yeah okay but he confessed they confess
to so much stuff in that case that's
probably the same thing they do here
they'd find all these people you know
cannibalizing other people and all this
stolen property and body parts and all
this inbreeding they're gonna go these
are demons yeah these aren't even humans
you know just like I said you just
started with soybean and black Agnes his
wife and suddenly there's 45 of them in
there so like a head you do the math
yeah they incest what's happening yeah
1,500 you know there was another time
you know they didn't play they don't boy
most definitely did not defending it not
in this situation yeah you play whether
this story is completely true or not or
whether it's exaggerated or whether it's
you know like a newer version of an
older story because like I said there
are a couple other older stories that
are very similar to this but as I said
it is very very well known folklore
legend history in Scotland and they you
know you can still do like a tour where
they like show you some of the supposed
locations where the cave was and all
this other kind of stuff so there's too
many other stories about Rob mass
robbery mass murder and cannibalism in
the old and going all the way to the
1800s
there's too much of common well [ __ ] was
going on to it that's not just based on
wild rumors that was happening yeah like
I said did they kill and eat a thousand
people I don't know but it's like I
don't think it's that far-fetched you
got 40 people in there there was a bunch
of them in a cave you got any you say
there are 45 people in there eat or it
ultimately 45 because they all had to be
born yeah but they're in there eating
regularly over 25 years yeah I can see
that yeah it's not like I see a thousand
how are you gonna catch that many
rabbits many people yeah and you see
that's like a one-stop-shop for them
well yeah we got all the money and the
money the clothing everything you need
to survive and the meat yeah all just
from robbing these people all they had
to do this is all on a night you jump
down a few demon you wouldn't even have
to go trade or you wouldn't even worry
about money so yeah yeah and like I said
that was like the whole story Sawney
bean didn't want to have to get a real
job I mean weird [ __ ] happens today you
don't think even weirder [ __ ] happened
in the 15 we seem to be like yeah I'm
sure yeah but some crazy [ __ ] [ __ ]
even a civilized person of the fifteen
hundreds really wasn't all that simple
exactly by our standards they would do
some [ __ ] that would [ __ ] turn your
hair white
yeah yeah it's like it was it was a
different time they turned day they they
got mad at people they damn tie rope
around their ankles there's a spin them
upside-down get two dudes and take a saw
and star saud yeah a living person from
the crotch hallway down into the ER and
they said that they would stop
and take a break what if when they got
about halfway through and these people
were alive
yeah they were [ __ ] cruel but that's
just the way they saw things yeah well
that's how they considered they
considered that justice you know Timon
and we talked about it making people
suffer for the evil that they've done we
talked about it for two it's like you
know the the idea that like every life
is precious or like everything that was
that is really rather much and no that's
a new doesn't know modern concept now
back in those days if you did something
wrong they were gonna make you suffer
and then they'd rationalize it
everywhere every people rationalized it
the Aztecs the English and everything
well if Jesus suffered and he was our
Savior you know I mean you're gonna
suffer even worse yeah if it was good
enough for Jesus this shit's gonna be
good yeah yeah so we're just gonna cut
you right yeah so their interpretation
of things was you know very different
than a modern interpretation yeah that's
why you know it's the same kind of
forces that cause people throw their
children into cenotes terrain gods and
you know cut people's hearts out and
people walk to the top of a temple
willingly to get their heart cut out
yeah because that was their religious
duty you know you know religious warfare
yeah people do all kind of crazy yeah
yeah yes so you just you know world was
the way it was yeah I mean you know it's
fascinating you think about from a
modern sensibility because yeah it seems
like most people nowadays just wouldn't
even imagine doing anything like that
but this is the [ __ ] Planet of the
Apes literally hey we're the Apes so
yeah I just like that like I said I eat
it's like yeah this could be like a
legend or exaggerated or something but
it would not surprise me if it hadn't
happened exactly like this and it's like
there's nothing crazy about that yeah
probably just like they say no I mean
well look what dudes look what look what
uh
royalty would and and nobility would do
yeah you know man yet Bathory yeah and
you'd have you know Vlad Tepes yeah it's
like even though I think that was it was
exaggerated probably like the numbers
might have been exaggerated but they did
do a lot of the [ __ ] that yeah you know
what
funny is that you know you look at vlad
the impaler and you in and you stand
he's kind of held up as like it's some
kind of demonic villain when in his
place in time he was held up as a hero
well he still is a hero who's a hero
yeah because he defended vilaça
and that was their ethos of the time was
that you're good to your friends and
you're ruthless to your enemies and then
impaling people is it sets an example
you know if you come in here you're
gonna [ __ ] pay yeah and you know that
works in a world without law and order
that actually works yeah you go you
can't go in there being nice to these
people they'll come back and kill you
yeah like somebody walking dead you know
first few seasons of Walking Dead back
Walking Dead was good
some in the medieval period in the
Renaissance period you know even even
really in some places today a lot of
people only understand force you gotta
rule them by terror if not they kill you
go down to Mexico go try to make friends
with them damn drug cartels watch your
hands it doesn't work that way yeah you
know work that way yeah so the tale of
Sawney bean as I said was the basis for
the hill that buys this one that Wes
Craven got that he because he did the
neighbor and I'm sure he - and he got
the whole camp burning sleeping death
thing but yeah he used that as the basis
for The Hills Have Eyes and pretty much
any pretty much any movie that's kind of
like about a bunch of inbred cannibals I
think and kind of I'm like look back at
this case cuz it's pretty famous
particularly in Scotland but you know
I've heard a lot about it I make a good
movie um I don't know if they've made a
movie about that specific case they may
have I make a movie about that set it
into fifteen hundreds and everything
that would be actually good I'm
surprised no one's really done that yeah
now that I'm thinking about it I mean
like I said they bought most of the
words like Texas Chainsaw Massacre it'd
be like Oh Tom Hawk it would be kind of
like that yeah maybe bone tomahawk was
kind of based on that shit's a little
bit yeah but yeah all right but yeah so
hills have eyes if you haven't seen it
it's based on this alright now the last
case that I wanted to talk about this is
so [ __ ] this is such a [ __ ] weird case
now this was actually the basis so far
of a 2016 Lifetime movie called The
Watcher which I have seen it's kind of
loosely based on that they changed a lot
of the details which I'll get into later
on but as I said earlier in the show I
believe that in late 2018 Netflix had
purchased the rights to this particular
news story with a view to making a movie
or a series about it
so we'll see how this goes now this is a
fairly recent story the crazy [ __ ]
started in June of 2014 now this is the
Broadus
family Derek and Maria and they had
three children who at the time in 2014
were five eight and ten years old now
the Broadus is had just purchased a very
nice 1.3 million dollar house in
Westfield New Jersey at 6:57 Boulevard
the house had been built I believe in
1905 it's a really nice house there's
pictures of it all over the web so I'm
not giving away anything about like the
address or everybody knows what the
address of it is so on this particular
evening in June 2014 they had purchased
the house but they were doing
renovations on it so they hadn't
actually moved into it yet but he's
Derek Brandes was at the house like you
know check and [ __ ] out and he checked
the mail and there was a bunch of junk
in there and then there was also this
kind of a white card like an envelope
and on the front of the envelope it said
the new owner like in this kind of thick
handwriting no put no postage there was
postage but there was no return address
okay I think most of these were
processed through because I think that
some of the [ __ ] that I saw about this
because I watched a couple kind of
documentaries or news stories about this
and some of them said that somebody was
just putting this stuff in their mailbox
without it going through the post office
but I think that's a misconception I
think it does it is actually going
through the post office but note there's
never any return address so this is the
new owner on it so he opens it and the
first two sentences sound kind of nice
kind of neighborly do your newest
neighbor dear dearest new neighbor at
six five seven Boulevard allow me to
welcome you to the neighborhood well
thank you very much total random
stranger however very quickly the led
got weird then it says how did you end
up here did [ __ ] it six five seven
boulevard call each call to you with its
force within six five seven boulevard
has been the subject of my family for
decades now and as it approaches it's a
hundred tenth day because as I said it
was built in 1905 I have been put in
charge of watching and waiting for its
second coming
my grandfather watched the house in the
1920s and my father watched in the 1960s
it is now my time do you know the
history of the house do you know what
lies within the walls of 6:57 Boulevard
why are you here I will find out now the
creepy thing about this is that
apparently this person whoever it is
that's writing these letters was already
watching them because he knew that they
drove a Honda minivan he knew that there
were contractors in the house doing
renovations on the inside because he
wrote I see already that you have
flooded six five seven Boulevard with
contractors so that you can destroy the
house as it was supposed to be bad move
you don't want to make six five seven
Boulevard unhappy he also knew that they
had three children because he says in
the letter you have children I have seen
them so far I think there are three that
I have counted he also asked if they
were gonna have more because he said
quote do you need to fill the house with
the young blood I requested better for
me was your old house too small for the
growing family or was it greed to bring
me your children once I know their names
I will call to them and draw them to me
okay this guy already sounds like he's
like a ghost buff I think he's totally
fabricated of course the history of
three generations of watching this damn
house you know it it sounds like a hoax
to me it sounds like sounds like
somebody who's just trying to stalk a
family well yeah clearly and he's gonna
put a paranormal spin on it he's been
watching too many forget episodes of the
haunting yeah that's what it sounds like
so far and I was the first time I've
ever here
this case yeah this actually it got a
lot of traction like a couple years back
just do that so [ __ ] weird so as I
said the envelope had no return address
on it but the letter went on to say Who
am I there are hundreds and hundreds of
cars that drive by six five seven
boulevard each day maybe I am in one
look at all the windows you can see from
six five seven boulevard maybe I'm in
one look out any of many window any of
the many windows in six five seven
boulevard and all the people who stroll
eat by each day maybe I am one then he
said welcome my friends welcome let the
party begin
and then the signature at the bottom was
actually not a signature it was just
like a script font because it was all
like in typewritten yeah and it was
signed The Watcher so Derek brought us
alarmed as you would be averse sounds
like the fantasies of a kid um well I'll
get into those okay so he turns off all
the lights in awakened C in the house he
calls the Westfield Police Department
now an officer comes out wreath the
letter says quote what the [ __ ] is this
because it's super weird now he asked
Derek he's like do you have any enemies
do you have any idea who might have sent
this to you and he's like no I have no
idea the cop was just like well you're
not
they weren't staying in there yet like I
said cuz it was still being renovated he
said well pretty much all I can think of
to do just move all this [ __ ] off the
porch just in case there is a guy like
hanging around here and he'll throw the
[ __ ] through the window and break in or
whatever so at this stage Derek and his
family kind of confer about this kind of
stuff now at first they didn't I mean
their kids were little they were only
like 5 8 and 10 so they didn't tell them
about the washer stuff because they
don't want to freak them out and they
hadn't moved into the house yet and they
were still staying in their old house
while the new one was being renovated so
what they did was they wrote an email to
the previous owners of the house John
and Andrea woods now they had actually
lived there for 23 years and at first
said that they had had no problems with
any weird you know letters or anything
like that now then they did say like
they get an email the next day from the
woods family and they said you know you
know we lived there for over 20 years we
never had anything happen but a few days
before we moved out we
a weird note too but since it wasn't
threatening pretty much all this letter
said that you know I've been watching
the house this whole time and you guys
took good care of it or something like
that they thought it was strange but
they didn't feel like it was threatening
so they just crumpled it up and threw it
out because it was anonymous and they
didn't know who it was from
so when the bharatas family went to the
police and we're like talking it about
the police said okay well I would advise
that you don't tell any of your
neighbors or any or any of your friends
or anything like that about these
letters because now like everyone who
lives around you is a suspect for doing
this because obviously it's someone that
is watching you they know what kind of
car you drive they know what's going on
in your house they know how many kids
you have and all this other kind of [ __ ]
so you know obviously over the next few
weeks even though they were still not
living in the house they were still
spending a lot of time there like
overseeing the renovations and whatnot
and they were a little nervous as you
would be because they had little kids
you know basically the guy cancelled a
work trip that he'd been taking on
because he didn't want it to leave his
wife and kids alone the kids they
wouldn't let him out of their sight
because they were afraid they'd wander
off and get kidnapped or whatever you
know and then there was like creepy [ __ ]
where they there was another couple on
the block that wanted to come in and see
the house like how it was being fixed up
and stuff so they were giving him a tour
and they said that the wife actually
said at one point quote it'll be nice to
have some young blood in the
neighborhood which they thought was a
little weird because of something they
said in the letter it was also some like
minor well there was also some minor
vandalism around like some kind of signs
that the contracts would put up there
were torn out [ __ ] like that now two
weeks after the first letter came
another letter arrived this one said
welcome again to your new home at six
five seven boulevard the workers have
been busy and I've been watching you
unload car foals of your personal
belongings the dumpster is a nice touch
have they found what is in the walls yet
in time they will this sounds like a kid
the
I think this is a kid living in one of
those houses in in the neighborhood not
I mean I'm picturing kind of like a 14
or a 15 year old [ __ ] kid listening
to black metal music he's been getting
off in the King diamondden [ __ ] thinking
about all these damn you know hauntings
and you know crimes that have happened
in houses going back generations and
ghosts and [ __ ] that's what I think this
is I don't think it's a homeowner I
think it's a I think it's the son of one
of the homeowners in that area maybe and
he's like me maybe he's like in 7th or
8th grade something like that
and he's [ __ ] with that family well
like I said I guess someone who's got a
lot of somebody's got a lot of time on
their hands yeah ok that's just my motto
ok so now in this letter apparently The
Watcher had learned their names he
called them mr. and mrs. Brad aswhat is
pretty close their name was brought us
it was a little bit misspelled he also
knew their kids birth order and their
nicknames which meant that he must have
been within earshot yeah because you
know the mom would would call their
names when they weren't playing in the
yard so it was obviously someone that
could hear her um yes so the letter says
I'm pleased to know your names now and
the name of the young blood you have
brought to me you certainly say their
names often he's got one of those
parabolic microphones yeah maybe next
weekend pointing and he's listening to
them talk to each other when they're out
front yard or getting into the car that
cut stuff and then over a period of time
he can piece together with people's
names are it's gonna be something like
their nickname it's not their real names
yeah well they hear me yeah so like I
said it had to be somebody that is to
hear them in that area he's Co and it
was somebody that could see in because
one of the girls like the daughter had a
little artists easel like on this
enclosed porch that was like it was
closed in and then it had like all these
trees around it and she would go in
there and paint or draw or whatever and
the letter said that he had seen the
little girl using the easel and asked is
she the artist and the family
got spy equipment you know he wants he's
got like I said he's got one of those
microphones that can hear a long
distance
he's got telescopes he lives within
eyeshot of that house yeah well that's
what they figured yeah tell me fast it
is a kid but okay so the letter goes on
to say six five seven Boulevard is
anxious for you to move in it has been
years and years since the Youngblood
ruled the hallways of the house have you
found all of the secrets it holds yet
will the Youngblood play in the basement
or are they too afraid to go down there
alone I would be very afraid if I were
them trying to scare it is far away from
the rest of the house if you were
upstairs you would never hear them
scream he's trying to scare him well
scare me if they were talking about my
kid holy crap and they know like all
this stuff about that because obviously
he's watching and listening to you they
saying the ghosts in the house are gonna
get him and that there's a season I
wouldn't in turn was trying to say he's
trying to say you know if you found this
to the dead bodies within the walls yeah
this is a [ __ ] this is a ghost story
I think yeah I think I think so far
we'll see yeah so there's some a kid
make up so it goes on to say will they
sleep in the Attic or will you all sleep
on the second floor who has the bedrooms
facing the street I'll know as soon as
you move in it will help me to know who
is in which bedroom then I can plan
better so that's not ghost he's talking
about him yeah oh no he's saying he's
deep he's saying he's saying he's spying
on him yeah he's also said he's also
basically try he's saying that that
there are ghosts in the house I suppose
yeah there's a saying that girl goes to
the house yeah yeah you talking about
you know the what's in the walls and
then watching it for generations and the
house is a killer and you know type of a
deal and it yeah I think he's trying to
say that houses on it yeah yeah so he
says excuse me all of the windows and
doors in 6.57 Boulevard allow me to
watch you and track you as you move
through the house who am i I am The
Watcher and have been in control of six
five seven boulevard for the better part
of two decades now the woods family
turned it over to you it was their time
to move on and kindly
when I asked them to yeah I passed by
many times a day six five seven
boulevard is my job my life my obsession
and now you are too Brad is family
welcome to the product of your greed
greed is what brought the past three
families to 657 boulevard and now it has
brought you to me
have a happy moving in day you know I
will be watching now at this point
because the kids had been threatened
Derek and Maria said okay well we're not
gonna bring the kids to the house
anymore and then they were like well now
they're reconsidering moving in because
like I said they hadn't moved in yet
they were still renovating now because
because they didn't move in when they
were technically supposed to three weeks
later another letter comes that says
where have you gone to six five seven
boulevard is missing you now as I said
this house in particular there hadn't
been any weird things about it prior you
know other than a few days before the
woods moving out they said they had got
kind of a weird letter but not a
threatening one so it seemed to be like
the Broadus were the target of the main
attacks so they figured out that the
letters though they had no return
address all the postmarks were from
tyranny in northern New Jersey now
interestingly the first letter was
postmarked June 4th and this was before
the sale of the house had been made
public so again they're thinking this is
somebody that lives in the neighborhood
who knows all of this stuff going on
because there had been no for sale sign
the woods had not put a for sale sign up
because when when they knew in the
neighborhood they were moving like they
had a lot of offers like very generous
offers even more than their asking price
because this is like a really really
nice house a really really nice
neighborhood so they didn't need to list
it they didn't need to put a sign in the
yard anything like that so interestingly
whoever wrote this letter wrote it
before the sale was public so this was
somebody must have been somebody with
some inside information
they also Derek and Maria also pointed
out how scary it was that he talked
about the little girl with the easel
because they said to see into that yes
it was a porch like an enclosed porch
but they said the porches covered up
by like trees and [ __ ] like you can't
just walk by the house and see into it
is what they're saying so they're
wondering how this person is like seeing
into it if they're like actually coming
up and looking into the [ __ ] [ __ ]
no you know they might just be claiming
to have the ability to do that you know
this person yeah but they knew about the
easel it's visible from where though the
backyard maybe no they said it wasn't
visible that's what they're saying they
said that there was it was an enclosed
porch and it's like there was like trees
all around it you know what I mean so
they were saying it would have been
really difficult to get right up on it
could it be could it be one of the
contractors or chair a kid of one of the
contractors possibly who knew about this
sale or you know so it's something like
that
it's somebody who knew that family the
old family was leaving and knew that the
other family was coming yeah that was
somebody in the housing commission or a
child of somebody who helps who runs the
Housing Commission if there is a
homeowner's association yeah something
like that somebody who's their kid has
access to that knowledge yeah and has a
lot of time on their hands and wants to
pull off this [ __ ] creepy hoax yeah
because this is not the kind of stuff
that a full grown mastermind criminal is
interested in it doesn't make profit and
it's not yielding any victims might just
be a crazy person though I mean it's
really it's a crazy crazy purse but I
kind of think it's more like a young
person has a lot of time on her hands
maybe his fantasy prom and kind of
getting off on this park I like a prank
phone call yeah something like that it
might be a person who's a little bit
older it's kind of like getting off on a
prank type phone call yeah having power
over people could be something like that
might but might have been one of the
somebody in connection with the sale of
that house yeah somebody one of the
crews or somebody in the housing
Commissioner something like that but so
the broadest says had been at a barbecue
in the neighborhood and Derrick gets to
talking to this guy named John Schmidt
who lived like two doors down from the
house that they had bought
now John Schmidt told him about this
family that lived in the house between
their houses and this was the Langford
family now Peggy Langford Langford was
90 years old like her in her 90s and a
bunch of her adult children who were all
in their 60s lived in that house with
her now everybody in the neighborhood
thought they were a little weird they
didn't think they were dangerous they
just thought they were like kind of
weird now one of the younger ones was
named Michael Langford and they kind of
like started looking at this guy a
little bit more closely because they
said um this guy he was either in his
50s or 60s or like an older guy they
were all older right so the a couple of
the things that they thought was
interesting was that the Langford house
was pretty much right next to where you
know the the enclosed porch was we liked
with the easel so somebody like that
across the road and look at like the
yard yeah
the family had actually lived there
since the 1960s so that kind of went
along the whole watcher thing and it's
like oh I've been watching a lot of blah
the father of the family who you know
would have been in societies actually
died 12 years earlier which kind of
lined up with the thing in the watcher
letter that said I've been on the job
for the better part of two decades so
maybe single ago I took over from my dad
or whatever so that kind of checked out
too a lot of time on his hands yes cuz
like I said these were all like retired
people and this Michael Langford didn't
he didn't have a job or anything like
that what did he do before I don't know
but they said like he had like a like a
big beard like Ernest Hemingway and but
that you know everybody in the
neighborhood thought that they weren't
dangerous but they thought they were a
little weird like yeah did he ever have
a job how do they lived off a family
well through his own I don't know like I
said it might have been because this is
like a pretty wealthy yeah area it's a
pretty well so like I said even this
particular house that this family moved
into is there were million dollars I
think you're onto something there that's
now well here's the thing though um so
the broadest family like approaches the
police and said hey do you know about
this length or family and they're like
yeah we do know about them and actually
a week after the first letter had
arrived they actually brought Michael
links
langford to the police headquarters and
interviewing him now michael said that
he didn't know anything about the
letters but according to the cop or at
least according to what the Parata says
later said the cop told them said you
know how he was saying things and like
how he's describing sounded a little bit
like the letter and they thought it was
kind of suspicious but they didn't have
enough hard evidence to hold him so at
this point you know the Broadus azar
kind of frustrated because they keep
getting these letters the police can't
really do much of anything because they
don't have any physical evidence at this
point I mean the letters don't have any
fingerprints or anything like that on
them so Derek decides he's gonna kind of
set up his own she sets up [ __ ]
cameras everywhere like you know
night-vision cameras he's got like the
lights he's got all this other kind of
[ __ ] and he starts like making all these
notes it's like and he made like these
maps of like you know who's with an
earshot of the house who can see the
house from which angle and all this
other kind of sub so he kind of got
obsessed with it and he said you know
his wife started thinking he was nuts
because he just like spent so much time
trying to figure out who the [ __ ] this
was but he made the point that is like
you know this person threatened my kids
you know what I mean he's like he said
quote it's like where I'm from if you do
that you get your ass beat well
obviously he wanted to find this [ __ ]
person if I don't who they were and he
knew that they had to be somewhere close
around there so he's basically trying to
stake out the place and like find find
out who this is
they also hired like you know very
special investigators like you from the
FBI and all this other kind of stuff to
look into it now they um they got this
former FBI agent and he kind of did a
profile on this person now in his
opinion because of the way that the
letters were written he thought that
maybe this was an older guy because he
says that the way the the envelope was
addressed was like m /m Radice like mr.
and mrs. and there's like nobody does
that anymore yes old fashioned [ __ ] and
he also said that he would sometimes
start like you know how you put like the
date like up in the corner
the letter and stuff like he would also
put like the weather up there like sunny
and cool for some which is something
that like old timey people used to do
also the letters were typed and they had
two spaces in between the sentences
which was something that they used to
teach you to do like a long time ago
yeah it's even some people still do it
nowadays in a dress oh my god like yeah
you used to have to do that with an old
[ __ ] typewriter like back in the day
but you don't have to do it anymore so
stop it because every now and that I
find some people that still do that like
in emails and stuff and it drives me at
the wall they also said the way it was
written suggested like I said an older
person and someone who read a lot um you
know what I mean
a shut-in yes somebody like that yeah
now there were also like a couple weird
like typos like a couple kind of
idiosyncrasies like one of the the first
letter was actually addressed like it
was dated Tuesday June 4th even though
June 4th was a Wednesday it this was
somebody that was uh you know what what
only written it [ __ ] near midnight
maybe yeah you know I mean I lost track
of time
yeah do they also noted that a lot of
the letters had what they called a
seething anger directed toward wealthy
people because one of the letters said
something about are you one of those
Hoboken transplants who were ruining
Westfield like they were bitching about
new people moving new money people
moving into the neighborhood somebody
who's never had job yeah so this might
be like an old like an old money type of
person and they don't like the people
moving in or something like that it just
seems really weird and you know another
one of the letters said something like
you know about the renovations that they
were making the house is crying from all
the pain at is going through you have
changed it and made it so fancy you were
stealing its history even though they
weren't doing anything super fan this is
a nice house like it's family I thought
but it cries for the past and what used
to be in the time when I roamed its
halls the 1960s were a good time for 65
7 Boulevard when I ran from room to room
imagining the life with the rich
occupants there the house was full of
life and young blood then it got old and
so did my father but he kept watching
until the day he died and now I watch
and wait
for the day when the young blood will be
mine again so he played in it as a kid
or so he said so he claims so at that
point because of that statement they
started investigating like maybe a
family that used to live there like had
a housekeeper and they had a kid and
like they're pissed off about the rich
people or something like that they're
like looking into all the egg could also
be just you know what I mean
diversionary [ __ ] [ __ ] it could be
that too like I said this could just be
like a completely fantasy part I mean
obviously this person is watching the
house obviously because they know all
this stuff about it but the thing about
it yes he's making threats it's like but
you you have to take that seriously I
mean because you never know like who's
gonna act on that kind of [ __ ] yeah he's
got a lot of time on his hands I guess
so yeah so now at this point they are
still kind of concentrating on this
Michael Langford guy and what they did
was they they wrote a letter to him in
the guise of over writing to everybody
in the neighborhood we're gonna tear the
house down because they wanted to see if
he would have any reaction but nothing
happened they also do it yeah they also
brought him in for a second interview
but that didn't go anywhere either at
this point his sister Abby's a you know
started accusing the police of harassing
them you know and all this other kind of
[ __ ] so and and they got a lawyer and
there was just like a whole big [ __ ]
thing
now even though Michael Langford does
sound like a pretty good suspect they
did the police did note they said look
we talked to him after the first letter
arrived at the Broadus house and then
another letter came after that and they
thought that if it was Michael Langford
and they thought that and he thought the
police were on to move be really stupid
to like send another one not saying that
it wasn't him I'm just saying that it
that would be kind of a dumb thing to do
and the police thought it was just kind
of a dumb thing to do they also said we
need to consider other you know you know
wider range of people in the
neighborhood because within a few blocks
of that house there were two registered
child sex offenders so they thought that
was a little weird
also um one guy who was there like
painting the bharatas house he said you
know you know when I was there painting
the house I saw this old couple
who lived in the house behind yours and
they have a pair of lawn chairs up in
the backyard that are very very close to
your house like weirdly close to your
house and it's like this there's this
older guy sitting in one of the chairs
and the chair was facing y'all's house
hmm you know what I mean so there's more
than one like sketchy [ __ ] in
this neighborhood what I'm saying so as
I said there are no fingerprints there
are nothing so by the end of 2014
you know they pretty much run out of
options you know of what to do next
you know the the broadest has had alarms
installed and all this other kind of
[ __ ] but they weren't sure if they
should actually like move into the house
or not like even though it had all these
alarms and stuff like I said they were
you know they were scared for their kids
safety because this person is clearly
watching them so and another thing too
is that as the time goes on and there's
deciding what to do about this house you
know they're still getting more letters
and they're seemingly getting weirder
and weirder like then they got one later
on that said six five seven Boulevard is
turning on me it is coming after me I
don't understand why what spell did you
cast on it it used to be my friend and
now it is my enemy
I'm in charge of six five seven
Boulevard it is not in charge of me I
will fend off it's bad things and wait
for it to become good again it will not
punish me I will rise again I will be
patient and wait for this to pass and
for you to bring the Youngblood back to
me six five seven boulevard needs
Youngblood it needs you come back what's
funny is if this guy actually believes
all this stuff that he's writing why
wasn't he writing this before to the
other people that live there that's
what's weird about Lee this is he's
claiming that he's been in on this
[ __ ] demon house for [ __ ] decades
they he didn't contacting anybody else
that lived there yeah I'm not buying it
I think it's a hoax but well yeah like I
said it could be is prank
not really not a prank yeah it's just
why why target this one family in
particular though like none of the other
four because that house had been there
since 1905 and somebody there had been
lots of people had lived in it somebody
just got a wild hang
[ __ ] somebody kind of snapped they
decided they were gonna do it yeah I
guess it just seems really weird I got a
I got a weird feeling that's kid but
it's it could be an old retired guy it
could be but I think it's me I mean the
FBI profilers seem to think it was just
because the way the letters were
structured and that sounded more like a
surprise you're probably right
yeah cuz why would a young kid like puts
you it's almost like a childlike fantasy
it is but it might be like a crazy old
yeah yeah maybe he's like reverted by me
maybe he had a stroke or something weird
happened in yeah
maybe he's you know certain just
happened all of a sudden he's talking
right so it could've been something like
that mental deterioration so at this
point the Broadus is are like that they
don't know what to do okay the their
previous house has already sold and they
are afraid to move into the new one
they've been staying with Maria's
parents and they're having all kind of
like preps like she had to go to a
therapist she had like PTSD then so they
both had to start taking sleeping pills
I think it will get all wrapped up over
this [ __ ] man like I said it's their
kids I understand the person that's
threatening their kids but you also have
to know [ __ ] artists when you see
and it's like do you really want to live
in a house and feel like somebody's
[ __ ] watching you every second of
every day because it seems like this
dude is like watching he knows what
they're doing and [ __ ] like that I don't
think I would have sent it the person
was lying yeah but I you know and yeah a
lot of people when this story went viral
a lot of us but I don't know if I would
want to live like that because they come
on I just say come on come into this
house come it you can come into this
house anytime you want to you're not
gonna leave but you can come in anytime
you want to but you won't leave this
house not in one piece yeah yeah well
yeah you know [ __ ] like this if you had
if you had kids that might be their
friend though I handle [ __ ] like because
the kids I'd have to every dish it's
like I don't have a damn call or camera
on all my kids yeah a body cam but
that's like is that really the way you
want to live though like I said it just
seems like and that's what the family
was saying it's like we feel like we'd
have to live in a fortress all the time
cuz we'd have to have all these alarms
it's like dude we'd have to watch the
kids every seconds they have to leave
they have to go to school it's like and
[ __ ] like that you know and
have to play in the yard it's like
somebody could snatch them it's like so
somebody really wanted those kids they
wouldn't say a word they'd just get him
I know but it's like this is somebody's
trying to use intimidation tactics and
spin a kind of yarn I wouldn't I
wouldn't believe it I wouldn't believe
it just yeah I mean I probably wouldn't
either but it would still freak me out
like cuz it would be something you would
think about all the time and it would
stress me out I don't think I would
probably laughed it off I don't think I
would like to live like that because it
just seems like harassment and you just
like feel like somebody's [ __ ]
watching all the time and I would hate
that so I can understand where they're
coming from and like I said especially
because they have little kids and the
little kids have to leave the house and
they worry about them so it's like I can
see that but so they decide okay so six
months of this [ __ ] [ __ ] like I said
they're living with Maria's parents
because their old house is sold and they
don't want to move into the new one so
finally they decide to that they're
gonna sell it
problem is there had been even though
they didn't really I mean they mostly
kept us on the down low because like I
said the cops are like don't tell all
your neighbors that you're getting these
letters because a lot of them are
suspects and we don't want it getting
out however um kind of [ __ ] got out
about it anyway particularly because
people started to wonder what you know
they bought this house and they did all
these renovations that are not moving in
so what the hell is going on and like
when their friends and [ __ ] would ask
them about it they'd be like oh we're
just having legal issues and that's all
they would say so everyone was starting
to think it was a little weird
and as I said [ __ ] started to get around
about the neighborhood that there was
like a stalker or a sexual predator or
there was something like that about the
house so they couldn't get any offers on
the house like even though they lowered
the price to like less than they had
paid for it and even people that were
like oh yeah and they said it didn't
bother them then they would like come to
the house and they'd be like yeah forget
it
like after they read the letters they're
like yeah I don't wanna I don't want to
do that now another might have been the
motive actually to drive people out of
the house and make it a bit could've
been he could run back through it like
he was a kid yeah might be something
like it could have been now one thing
that the broadest family did you and I
and I respect this actually they told
that their their realtor who was from
Coldwell Banker they said we are going
to like people that come and are
interested in in buying the house we are
going to partially disclose that there
is a purse
that says that they're watching the
house and they will send letters and
blah blah blah because they said we
would hate for someone else to buy the
house and have the same thing happened
to them now I should note that in New
Jersey
apparently it you don't have to disclose
if there was like a murderer a haunting
or whatever because like some states you
have to like New York you have to like
if you're selling a house if someone was
murdered in it or if it's supposedly
haunted there was like a famous case I
think it was in Long Island where they
legally ruled that the house was haunted
and so like that that's something that
you have to disclose in New Jersey you
don't have to but they decided that they
would anyway now they said now if
somebody was interested enough to like
make an offer on the house then we will
let them read the letters so they know
what they're getting into just in case
which I think that's kind of a cool
thing for them because that would kind
of suck to like buy a 1.3 million dollar
house and then like you have some
[ __ ] crazy dude like right in you all
the time that's something I think I
would like we know what I would do is
every time somebody damn me help me one
of those letters I just wouldn't open it
yeah they ride to the police yeah you
just give a regular just read with you
know the police to evidence that they
need and I wouldn't I wouldn't let that
dude try to [ __ ] you and [ __ ] with me
yeah yeah I mean I just send the letter
right to the police who even open it
yeah that's that that's how you deal
with that but um yeah so another thing
that happened to was that because of the
whole thing that they went through with
the disclosure and everything the
Broadus is decided to sue the woods
family for not telling them about the
weird [ __ ] that they had got before they
moved out
and it turned out that because I think
it was like a reporter from a local
newspaper actually saw the complaint and
they saw some of the excerpts of the
Watchers letter and he ended up
publishing it and that's how the story
went viral you know what I mean so
that's kind of how just because of the
lawsuit between the two of them now the
lawsuit was actually dismissed and the
Broadus has appealed but that was also
thrown out and they just got like all
after it went you know after the the
story broke nationally then they got all
kind of [ __ ] media requests and all
this kind of [ __ ] but they didn't really
want to do it at this point they went
and stayed
friends beach house and ended up having
to tell their kids what was going on
because the kids didn't have any idea
like I said um you know so there was a
lot of nervousness and in the
neighborhood a lot of the neighbors were
pissed because they felt like the
Broadus has had lowered their property
values and all this other kind of [ __ ]
that they would say and the cops didn't
really seem to be catching anybody now
another thing that came out later on
about Michael Langford one of the first
suspects was that another reason why
they suspected him is that because when
he was younger he had been diagnosed
with schizophrenia and he was actually
known to walk through other people's
yards and look in their windows even
though no one had thought that
particularly alarming at the time and I
guess he'd never been like reported the
police or anything like that and when
they asked some of the neighbors about
it they're like oh well we never thought
he met any harm he was just kind of
doing like checking on people you know
what I mean so that was kind of weird
now it did turn out later on though that
they were able to get DNA off of one of
the envelopes of The Watcher letters
like I guess from the myth like and
guess what the DNA was from a woman okay
so then they start investigating Michael
Lankford's sister because they did
definitely think that maybe it has
something to do with that family
yeah but the Langford family are adamant
that it is like nothing she was like
we've lived here for however long I mean
their family had lived there for like
decades and decades it's like we never
cause anybody trouble and like suddenly
this family tries to move in and they
start getting all these letters and now
everybody's accusing us and all this
other kind of [ __ ] there was also some
[ __ ] that came out and give up any DNA
yeah no match okay so the cops have
specifically said no one in this
Langford household lays responsible for
unless they put somebody else's DNA on
that thing on purpose what they were
that smart no that's not yeah yeah so
but the police did supposedly tell the
processes they're like look we don't
think it's anybody in that house because
the DNA doesn't match anybody in that
house
it doesn't match anybody in that family
so unless like you said they
specifically put it because somebody
apparently none of the other letters had
fingerprints or DNA or anything it was
just this one letter that they got it
off of and it was a it was a female DNA
but like I said like you said it they
could have got it from anywhere they
could have stole it from somebody yeah
and then stole that DNA
somebody and then wrote a letter on it
sent it over there and it says watch you
know
watch him said you know this will clear
us yeah I mean that would that be
something a genius would do whoever it
is has a lot of spare time clearly yeah
and and would do diversionary tactics
yeah true yeah another person they
looked into was the 21 year old son of
the woods who were the couple that had
lived there before but they don't think
it was him either
another very broadly and this is kind of
and I and I don't I don't I don't think
this is true but a lot of people
especially when this story kind of went
viral and shown up on Facebook and stuff
a lot of people thought that the Broadus
is pulled it as a hoax
either because motivations that people
put forward were either that oh they
bought this super expensive house and
then realized they couldn't afford it
and so thought they would pull this is
like some kind of elaborate thing to get
out of it that's that's plausible yeah
but it's just I mean they went through
so much trouble and stress they never
actually lived in the house they never
moved into it okay I mean they they
lived in their old house for a while
then their old house sold then they
moved in with Maria's parents and then
they weren't sure if they were gonna
move in the house because of the [ __ ]
letters so then they moved then they
moved to their friend's beach house so
they didn't really get anything out
paying for that house and they were
paying for it while they were yeah they
were paying the mortgage and the
property taxes on it the whole time how
to move right in so why would they do
that
how to drop my nuts and move right into
that damn house I probably would have to
well like I said I would still worry
about it though
I'd say coming in and get me man coming
to get me you know but I think that to
me the way you decide I've deciphered in
those letters I didn't see that as a
threat directly from the writer onto the
kids
I thought the writer was saying that the
demons and the ghosts in the house and
that the house was kind of possessed and
that the house would hurt the kids
yeah that's how I'm interpreting it that
he's trying to do a haunted house story
and maybe that's how I interpreted it I
mean later on like as the investigation
went on they discovered that that
another family on the street had also
gotten a similar letter but they had
also thrown it away they didn't have any
little kids so they weren't super
worried about it they just thought it
was weird somebody living on that block
has some kind of way they know that it
has to be somebody that lives around
there it has to be yeah because this is
somebody that no one notices I mean no
one notices anybody like crawling around
in these people's backyard or like
looking in there when is no one notices
somebody that they talk to I think and
if they don't suspect yeah that's real
harmless and they're in there living
living this fantasy life or writing
these [ __ ] weird as the letters yeah
and you know waking people out now some
people some people have also accused the
Broadus ha's of like trying to pull in
Amityville Horror kind of [ __ ] reminds
me of that I think about it is that yeah
they're one they're not profiting off it
because they turn down like most media
offers because they're like we don't
want the [ __ ] deal with it and when
lifetime wanted to make a movie about it
they didn't want him to do it and they
sent them like a cease and desist to
make them stop but the movie went ahead
anyway they changed some details like I
said that the movie was actually set in
LA the the person was called the Raven
and they you end up like in a in a bird
suit and [ __ ] like you can make people
uh people kind of make a lot of
assumptions this isn't in the 1970s
anymore you can't make a lot of money
with a paranormal story no like we've
got all kinds of offers for for mammoth
mountain there's no money involved in
them and we take we'd like the thing
that we did for NPR radio we making
money on that now did that for free
because we wanted to yeah you know it
didn't even really sell any books it
didn't even really have much of an
impact on that we've had some other
people come and offer damn television
stuff but we're really skeptical that
you you don't make any money on it's
just kind of a waste of time really yeah
I mean I don't mind doing it just like
to get [ __ ] out there like to you know
to raise the yeah you know kind of it's
almost I got the book there people like
you know they want to buy the book they
can buy the book I guess you you would
think that if there was a television
program that it would sell books but it
doesn't though they just watch the TV
program yeah they don't buy the book so
it's mostly yeah
yeah it's not like 1972 where you can
have a [ __ ] book and a book go out to
make a millions of dollars this that era
is long gone
well especially like you said with
something paranormal yeah paranormal
[ __ ] nobody goes [ __ ] about that so yeah
so I really don't think even though the
family and it sucks because like this
family has been subjected to a great
deal of abuse both online and elsewhere
and because they still live in Westfield
they actually ended up buying another
house like in the same town because that
was where Maria the wife that's where
she had grown up and she wanted her to
raise her kids there I mean
understandably um but she's like she
can't go anywhere now without people
knowing who she is and it's like you
know she runs into people from that
neighborhood all the time and it's
really awkward so it's like you know
kind of sucky so as far as I know the
only other suspect that they had some of
the investigators were actually staking
out the house one night they were
sitting the back of a van with some
binoculars around 11:00 p.m. they see a
car stopping in front of the house for
long enough that the inspectors thought
it was a little suspicious so they ended
up tracing the car to a young woman who
lived the next town over
now her boyfriend lived on that block
she was scoping him out mmm she's out no
the cops were staking out that house
okay and then this car stopped in front
of that house okay for a long time and
they traced the car to this woman she
lived the next town over her boyfriend
lived on that block she wasn't staking
her own boyfriend
I don't know who was in the car though I
don't know she was in the car he was in
the car now I got some women out there
that'll stake out a man's house to see
if she's maybe but that wasn't no no
well that that wasn't his house that
they were checking out the house that
yeah maybe they heard about the story
that's possible too but the I mean they
just wanted to check it out so they
thought now this is a little you know a
little bit of a stretch but like I said
they have to like investigate everything
so they interviewed this woman and she
said that her boyfriend played some
quote/unquote dark video games I guess
like for horror video games or something
like
and had a plate and had a character that
was named The Watcher so hmm weird I
don't know weird yeah so the boyfriend
was not living on that street anymore
now they called him and he said that he
would come to the police and be
interviewed but he never showed up
did the letter stop um I think that they
have stopped at this point and did they
ever move into the house
no but they they they never moved to the
house they bought another house in the
same town they rented this house out
okay so those people never got any
letters uh I don't think so like the guy
that lived there he he has a thing he
won't tell anybody his last name he just
goes by Chris because he doesn't want
the media attention um he said that
there was a little codicil in his lease
that if he got any letters that he could
break the lease without being he said he
said her boyfriend lived up the street
in here he used to yeah he used to and
that that was his screen name how old
was the boyfriend what does she thought
I was she talking about I don't know her
I said I thought it was a young guy who
had a lot of time on his hands
and somebody who's ended kind of like
ghost stories and [ __ ] yeah he played
dark video games we're talking about
they're talking about you know Silent
Hill I don't know I don't even know what
that means yeah I don't know and like I
said I I'm a little bit skeptical of
that too because you know how people are
was like oh the video games and he
played this then the other thing where
it's like you know everybody plays video
games it's not like a weirdo saying it's
just like I don't know so it's just like
the way they used to say people that
look listen to heavy metal I'm sure they
all worship the devil says man [ __ ] off
with that so it just sounds like old
people like talking about young some of
that real sinister [ __ ] though it turns
out to be mundane crap like they found a
damn VH a VHS tape in the garbage or it
was sitting on the side of the road and
somebody watched it and it's like the
maniacal laughter of you know I see you
see it I see it burning you know it's
this house burning and they're going
what the [ __ ] what house is that and
what it is on fire who's this satanic
mother
and it took him years to find out who
that was on the videotape in what house
was on fire yeah and it was a teenage
kid who lived in a house he's pretty
they said he was cool the cop said he
was real cool because they they found
him later and he used he grew up playing
in some woods and that would just got
purchased by some developers and why
they were building houses in there he
said some of them on fire yeah
any videotaped it I know I know that sir
I know that story yeah and he we watched
it together yeah well now I'm telling
his gem the tone the audience yeah okay
remember there's more than one person
here so he's he had his whole garage set
up like a damn haunted house and they
were making films and videos in there to
each other and he was talking to his
buddy
was his buddy cat or lock or something
like that he had all these weird names
for his prints yeah yeah and it turns
out that he ended up sending him to like
counseling really yeah if you were to
just see that videotape they thought
that they were dealing with like some
kind of weird serial arsonist er yes
serial murderer you know what I mean
but he was just role playing he was
LARPing yeah he did set some [ __ ] on
fire you know he did some time for it
but I think he did some time and kind of
like a like a mental place I'm gonna say
mental home but you know yeah mental
hospital or something you know yeah make
sure he wasn't totally off his [ __ ]
rocker but really you know it was just
teenage kids you know acting crazy
yeah [ __ ] yeah but yeah so like I said
now there was some other [ __ ] I didn't
get into with this we're like you know
at first like before the Barneses like
rented the house out they try to get
like the house tore down the lot split
all this other kind of stuff and they
wouldn't let him do it and I think I
said before that the letter stopped they
did not I was mistaken about that
apparently like I said this this family
you know move into the house they rented
it they had a thing in their lease it
said you know if we get any letters we
can break the lease if we want to do
that and not get punished for it now two
weeks after I think
to the renter's moved in now Derrick
brought us they're still the owners of
the house obviously so there were some
squirrels that were like all up in the
roof so Derrick comes to the house to
take care of it and the renter hands him
a letter that had just arrived that very
day and it said violent winds and bitter
cold to the vile and spiteful Derek and
his wench of a wife Maria you wonder who
the watcher is turn around idiots
maybe you even spoke to me one of the
so-called neighbors who has no idea who
the watcher could be or maybe you do
know and are too scared to tell anyone
good move
they also knew all about all the media
that had happened you know after the
story went viral because he said I
walked by the news trucks when they took
over my neighborhood and mocked me
I watched you as you watched from the
dark house and an attempt to find me
telescopes and binoculars or wonderful
inventions he also knew about the
attempts that the Broadus had made to
get the house torn down and the lot
split because there was like all these
big meetings about it you know what I
mean and that finally that their request
was denied because the Lots would be too
small and all other illegal kind of [ __ ]
so what the letter said was six five
seven Boulevard survived your attempted
assault and stood strong with its army
of supporters barricading its gates
because there'd been a lot of people at
the meeting that didn't want that to
happen because they said the houses
would be ugly or they'd be too small or
whatever I'm sure he was at that meeting
well yeah I'm sure he was that's why he
probably said you know turn around
idiots or whatever yeah because I'm sure
he was probably there because like I
said I'm sure he probably lived in the
neighborhood and that's who was at that
meeting he says my soldiers of the
boulevard followed my orders to a tea
they carried out their mission and saved
the soul of six five seven boulevard
with my orders all hail the watcher this
guy also mentioned the name of the
person that was renting the house so
they and the renter had just moved in
like a couple weeks prior
now the renter was like freaked out
because they had mentioned him by name
in this particular letter but he said he
will stay on the condition that you
install camera and more cameras like all
around the house and around the mailbox
and everything like that so just a case
like some more [ __ ] happens somebody
knows a commission so maybe he also said
that if the renter did anything specific
that he didn't like her if the family
did anything specific that he didn't
like he said that revenge would come in
many forms maybe a car accident maybe a
fire maybe something as simple as a mild
illness that never seems to go away but
makes you feel sick day after day after
day
maybe the mysterious death of a pet
loved one suddenly died planes and cars
and bicycles crash bones breaks that is
getting all terrorists to calm people
yeah well that's essentially what this
is it's kind of like emotional terrorism
sure he's full of [ __ ] yeah maybe so as
I said getting off on his power trip
yeah they have no idea who this person
could be other than it's got to be
somebody in the neighborhood or like the
son of somebody in the neighborhood
maybe an old guy in the neighborhood but
yeah so like I said this is a [ __ ]
weird-ass case it's still kind of
ongoing fathers of cops phones the cops
I was just announced that all letters
will not be opened they're just gonna be
sent to the police yeah and that just
clips all the [ __ ] nuts off with off
yeah because if this person isn't really
gonna do anything and they're just
trying to get a ride if it does
something all right then the best course
of action is to denies ability to denies
or it's like not let it up sighs yeah
what you do is you deny his ability to
communicate with with the victims so
what you do is you just the police
announced that all mysterious letters
will just be sent to the police they
won't be open yeah so that means just
the police get this and they can build a
case then yeah that would probably the
neighbors don't even know that probably
don't know that's how I was because like
you said I mean yeah if I had kids and
you know we have and he did threaten
animals also so I'd be afraid for ya
[ __ ] threat it's the threat and if you
got a live animal without the threat
then there's no power in it yeah because
the victim didn't even know the victim
never even heard the threat yeah so
that's what she did you just that
probably would just sign it he'd have
done so just don't just don't open that
he had done something already
wait he's harmless he's either a little
wimpy guy or a kid or he's an old man
that's harmless I kind of suspect it's
an old man
I'm making old lady but probably more a
crazy old lady yeah and and and it may
not be there's some reason it sounds
like a man to me though yeah it kinda it
could be that he's not really getting
off so much on all these threats
what he is is he can become the hero in
front of everybody that he's trying to
catch this person or he's trying to save
these people it's something like that
almost kind of like a Munchausen by
proxy yeah you know I mean how much I
bet he's real helpful yeah he's weird
yeah he's real helpful he's taking care
of people so he's the threat and the
solution there's gonna be that that
angle is probably going on this serial
killer [ __ ] there look cause a lot of
them will like help look for the victims
and like yeah be super forthcoming well
their lives are the victims so they can
find out what you thought yeah but then
to it's likely if the body's found plus
they think it's kind of like you know
social kiting in plain sight yeah yeah I
think they get off on them yeah but I
don't think he's doing he may be doing a
little bit of that but I betcha he's
also helping yeah oh man that's terrible
you know he's one of those kind of guys
well the thing about it too it's like I
said I don't blame the family for not
moving in because not only is it just
like constant stress and you got to
worry about your kids but also you can't
trust any of your neighbors because it
could be any one of them so it's like
you can't talk to them you can't like
every time you went outside the door
you'd be like is it that guy no that was
thought he knows all about that that
would suck he knows he's doing that it's
just it it's a game yeah this is a game
it's not serious if this dude was a
[ __ ] dangerous he'd have done
something already yes well no I don't
know if I would risk it he's in person
he's probably very timid yeah and I
think the profiler did say something
like that this was like I'm not macho
yeah yeah I'm very timid and you'd never
know you'd never suspect him because
he's not an imposing figure and he's not
threatening and you know I mean that
that's all this is and like I said even
though the DNA that they found on the
envelope was a woman's DNA I don't know
just something about the letters the way
they're written sounds like a man to me
sounds like a man he got some he got an
envelope too or a letter that was
contaminated with female DNA and he knew
it was maybe that's what it is maybe
that many wrote a letter on there
because none of the other ones had that
yeah I mean and you could easily just
use like gloves and like a little sponge
to check it he could check and see if
they were looking for DNA that kind of
stuff yeah see and that yeah that that's
a good he could get feedback on his case
so he could so he could see what was
gonna see what was going on he had peace
of mind yeah I mean to see if he was
they were on to him that type of deal
yeah he wanted he wants to know what the
investigators know yeah he wants to know
if they're closed if they're closed yet
they're not closed though yeah because
it's a low priority I must say that the
criminal profile the criminal
investigators just see him as a nuisance
yeah because he hasn't actually done
anything he's gonna physically harm
anyone well the guys that are dangerous
don't give any warning they just kill
and rape murder and then maybe they
might communicate after they usually do
it afterward yeah yeah so you know this
guy is just he's not he's not like that
he's not he's not he's not it that's not
what he's out after yeah I think he's
after the power of making people jump
when he says jump and then he could step
in and as the heroic occasionally you
know man yeah it held these people I bet
you he's like a real helpful
[ __ ] probably yeah just like old
Dennis there okay kind of like old
Dennis you know burger bro
my voice isn't good so I can't do well
he was he was here in spirit he was his
little bobble head was here here and he
was here with the Raven yeah cuz like I
said the the lifetime movie that they
made about the watcher case the the
actual guy that was sending them [ __ ]
was not called he didn't call himself
the watcher he call himself the Raven
and every now and then you'd see like
somebody like show up in like a creepy
bird costume actually I liked the movie
in the beginning but then I don't know
it didn't really stick I remember that I
saw it and I remember like the first
part it was kind of creepy like there
was the person in the bear suit but
other than that but you know this case
like I said is like there's a like a lot
more like complicated like legal [ __ ]
and a bunch of other [ __ ] that
I didn't really have time to get into
but if you want like a really exhaustive
like breakdown of this case go to this
website called the cut and they did like
a humongous and that's mostly where most
of my notes came from because they sit
like a humongous thing you know that we
can't just guy to they probably know I
mean I'm if he keeps writing letters
yeah he's gonna [ __ ] up it always and
it's got to be somebody around there it
has to be so the the big the suspect
pool is very small okay all the ways
somebody on that you're communicating
with law enforcement or your victims you
get caught eventually you will yeah
because you're gonna make a mistake
everybody makes mistakes yeah you know
yeah and it's usually something that
they never really see common yeah
exactly
so you know we'll see how that goes and
I'm kind of excited to see this Netflix
thing that they're gonna make if it ever
comes out yeah like I said I think they
just got the rights in December of last
year so I don't know how long it's gonna
take to make a movie about it out of
that all right so that will do it for
this probably extra long multi you know
this topic show hope you guys enjoyed it
I thought it actually had a lot of fun
doing this one it was kind of fun all
this all the different [ __ ] you know
variety of things for everybody
mmm so remember if you liked the show
like share subscribe and all your social
media if you really really like the show
and you love us very much then you can
go to our patreon page or you can go to
our blog 13 o'clock podcasts not
WordPress calm and there's a little link
in the sidebar if you'd like to get
one-time donation through PayPal that
would be very much appreciated and that
will do it for episode 163 we will see
you next time bye
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]